[音楽]今日は皆様の超能力か私の超能力か
自然の流れかわかりませんだけど
良い天気にはなりました
こう夏っていうのはあまり仏教の話を聞く時期ではなくてね
遊びに行く時期なんですけど
皆様方はもしかすると楽しいだろうと
いらっしゃったかもしれませんだけど
まあ必ず期待は裏切れると思います
全然面白い話にはならないかもしれません
しかし ちょっと我慢して今日の話を聞いていただきたいんです
なぜならば 勉強することは何よりもとてもありがたいことなんです
ですから 我々はやはり死ぬまでいろいろいろいろことを勉強して
勉強してね 自分の状況をね
心の状況をね どんどん向上させていった方がよろしいんです
今日の話も もしかするとちょっと理解難しいかもしれませんだけど
まあ知識ぐらいでも増えるだろうということで
聞いていただいて聞いていただきたいとは思っています
で 質問する時間を作らなくちゃあかんだから
できるだけ早いスピードで話を進めます
今日のテーマはね 執着を捨てるとどういうことっていうことですね
でお釈迦様がこの 4つの執着を語られているんですね
まあ執着といえばね 言葉の定義は要らないと思いますけど
普通一般的には日本語の意味でもある執着ですね
まあいわゆる離れない
離られない 離れない 離れないというね
まあ時々我々は忘れ 忘れられないとか何とか言ったりするでしょ
何か出来事があって それは決して忘れませんとかね
忘れられませんとかね
忘れられませんというと
かなり執着ですね そこで執着っていうのは心理学的にどんな機能かと見えてくるんです
これだけはいくらなんでも忘れ忘れられませんよと
で その時ははっきりと執着は働いてますね
そういうことで離れられない状況
あれは心理学的な状況なんですね
それがまあ執着ということにするんですね
ただ 毎日ご飯を食べているんですけど
執着あるかどうかね ありますけど
我々は毎日食べるご飯に対してそんなに執着あると思ってないんですね
そこでたまたまごっついもう豪華なごちそうを食べたならば
どこかで宮廷料理でもね
一生一回でもいいんだけどね
もし食べたならば それだけは忘れ忘れられませんね
その時は執着がはっきりと働いているんです
皆様方はね また ご自分の写真やら記録
記録やら写真に残るよりも
子供のことならもうもう立ったたらもうビデオを撮っている
座ったらまたビデオ撮っている
転がったらまたビデオ撮っている
ご飯こぼしたらまたビデオ撮っていると
なんだこれはと 鮮明に日にちもかけて全部かけて
全部もうビデオで撮って記録しておくでしょ
あれが執着なんですね
ただ単に客観的に まあ人の成長は記録してしておいた方がよろしいと
後で何がしか役に立つかもしれませんとかね
そんな気持ちは毛頭ないでしょ
そんな気持ちありません
とにかく取っておきたいだけ
ビデオを全部自分でもう抱え込んで抱きしめていたいんですね
そういうふうに この物事から離れられない状況を作る心のエネルギーが執着なんです
これ なんで全て無常なのにわからないんですかね
あれ 執着という精神的な働きが全部つなげちゃうんです
繋げたものは存在しないんです
だから 1個 1個 1個出来事を起きて消えて
起きては消えて 起きては消える
いつでも今の現在で 1個の出来事しかないんですけど
我々の執着って過去からこういう風に
こういう風に私が生きてきましたとかね
全部繋げてしまいますね
幻覚で あの幻覚であれをつなげることは
執着という精神的なエネルギーでやっているんですね
そういうふうに この我々みんなに
この そういう執着という
この粘着剤ですね あって
粘着剤というよりもね
あの あの鎖の一個一個のリンクがあるんですね
だから一個だけしかないんだけど
そのリンクに後ろと前にもう 2つつなげますね
それで長いリンクが鎖が出来上がるでしょう
このつなげるこのフックの働きなんですね
今ご飯食べてると美味しいと感じながら
もうちょっと一つのフックが出来上がっちゃうんですね
美味しいという感じ 感情の中に
それにまた何か引っかかって
次の現象がそちらのフックに引っかかって止まる
それでつなげているように感じちゃうんです
食べたご飯の現象が終わっちゃったんだけど
で そこの現象にまた新しいフック
フックがあって そうやってどんどん我々にはずっともう無限の過去からもう無限の将来まで自分がいるんだという
こういうこの錯覚が生じてしまうんですね
それがこのウパーダーナという執着ということなんですね
で いきなりお釈迦様の言葉は経典で始まります
今日はできるだけ私の解説は避けます
これはもう我々の人でもそんなに簡単なテーマじゃないんです
カタマンチ ビッケウェー ウパーダーナン チャッタリマニ ビッケウェー ウパーダーナーニ
比丘たちよ 執着はいくつでしょうか？執着は 4つです
これ 仏教のすごいところ
自分勝手に言ったってもね
皆様そうじゃないと思ってるしね
私は仏教は世界一すごいと思ってますからね
ガチャガチャいろんなことを言う必要はないんです
で いろいろ批判する人々
私は脳細胞抜けて生まれた人間だと思ってるんです
生まれた時からもう脳の精子の中で何もなかったと
だからブッダの教えはもう人類は誰も語られてない
ものすごい完璧なすごい教えなんです
わからないんだったら黙っていればいいでしょう
ブッダに悪口言わないで
私がわかってるわけでもないんですよ
一部の一部は理解できたんであって
理解できないところはものすごくあるんですよ
そういうことで お釈迦様のこのすごいところは
この執着といえば なんとなくみんな知っている
今 この写真の例でね 言ったでしょ
なんかやっぱりもう一度その思い出を
いわゆる思い出にしたい
決して欲しくない だから写真撮っておく
あの働きが執着なんです
どこかに旅行にすれば
旅行にして楽しくて楽しがって戻って帰ればいいでしょう
それで物足らない パチパチパチパチパチパチ
全部写真撮るんですね
それからアルバム作って
もう見て見て見て またあの過去の楽しみを思い出すんですね
そんな馬鹿げたことをやらせているのは
執着という精神的な働きなんです
はい それぐらいはなんとなくわかりますね
しかし それは４種類ですよと
は 人間には理解できないんです １
種類じゃないんです ４
種類ですよと カーモーパーダーナンディットーパーダーナンシーラッバトゥーパーダーナンアッタバードーパーダーナンという
1 愛欲執着 愛欲と私は勝手に入れたんですけど
ちょっとなんかあの翻訳の言葉は気に入らなかったんです
2番目は見解執着  3番目は戒律執着
4番目は我論執着 日本語の単語が難しいと思うならば
パーリ語で覚えてください
で こういう4種類があります
はい それから一個一個説明していきます
1 カームパーダーナン
カームパーダーナン で
カーマという言葉がありまして
カーマはとはこの場合
欲ではなく欲の対象なんです
そこでよくこのこんがらがっちゃうんで
仏教仏典で同じ単語を使うんですよ
この精神的にある欲にも欲という単語を使うし
そうではなく この欲の対象にも欲というんですね
で 区別するときはもうちょっと形容詞を入れますけどね
欲の対象って何ですかね
これまた心理学的に分析します
あの 俗世間の話ではなく
もうこれから全部この専門的な話になります
仏教心理学になります
眼耳鼻舌身意という 6つの感覚器官があります
我々人間に 他の生命にも目耳鼻などなどという 6つの感覚チャネルがあります
感じるチャネルが 窓口が6つあります
それらに色声香味触法という 6つの対象が触れるんです
この 6つの窓口に接近する情報がよく 6種類あるんです
目には色形とか情報が接近して触れる
耳には音というものが触れる
舌には味というものが触れる
体には感覚という単語しかないんだけど
もう冷たい 硬い 熱いとかね
そういう感じるものは心から体に触れる
意にはデータやらアイデアやら考え方やら感情やら心にぶつけて触れるんですね
だから六感で五感ではなくね
西洋では五感 五感と言いますけど
仏教は六感 六感と言うんですね
西洋的には現代的には六感はようわからないと
でも我々は あなたはどうやって怒ったのか
あなたはどうやって嫉妬したのか
あなたはどうやって考えているのかとかね
例えば目の前にものがなくても考えられるでしょ
例えば子供に紙に書いて数学の質問を出すと
子供はこの紙のある質問を読んで理解しようとする
考える その場合は目から情報が入ってますけど
ではそれから一人でできますからね
紙を取り上げても 頭であれやこれやと考えることはできますよ
ですから それは６番目なんです
そういうことで六感があります
六感に入る情報は決まってます
情報は明確に えーと 分
何て言いますか 分かれています
ごちゃ混ぜになりません
目で感じるものは耳でも感じられるとか
それはないんです しっかりと仕事別に分かれています
目に見えるのは形と色
そのデータしか受け取れない
耳は音というデータしか受け取れません
味はさっぱりわかりません
耳で 鼻で香り以外何もわかりません
舌は味しか何も認識しません
ちょっと誤解するのは
例えばベロが舌でありながら肉体の一部もありますね
だから舌を触ったらわかりますね
それは体なんです 味じゃないんです
味を感じるところでは味しか感じません
それで熱いものを食べて熱いとかね
火傷したとかあったり場合は
あれは味ではなくて この肉体が火傷しているんです
味の感覚ではないんです
ちゃんとデータがお互い混雑することなく
明確に自分自分のチャネルに分かれて体に入るんです
この体にデータが触れることは
触という専門用語で仏教を使っています
この 6つの対象に執着します
それで私たちはこの対象に執着する
対象っていうのは 色声香味触法なんです
見えるものに執着する
美しい花やら公園やら
あれは自分のものでという感覚要りませんよ
私は私のものに執着している
そんな話じゃないんですよ
見えるものに執着する
なんて綺麗ですかとかね
あの公園はとても綺麗で
あの向こうの夏 昼は向こうで行って弁当食べて
ちょっと昼寝でもしようかなとかね
で 考えている時は この人の公園ですけど
誰かのね やっぱり執着しているんです
だから この目に触れる対象に執着する
耳に触れる音に執着する
味に執着する 皆様方は死骸食べたい？で
食べてるで 死んだ動物の死骸なんかは食べる気持ちにならないでしょう
では なんでうなぎに高いお金を払って買ってるんですかね
味に執着しているんです
どう見たって生きてるうなぎ見たら
こんな食うのかいと 気分になると思いますよ
ヘビみたいな感じで 頭三角形でかっこ悪いし
で 生きているうなぎ見ても皆様は気持ち悪いと全然思わないんですよ
なぜかというと 頭がおかしくなっています
味に執着しているんです
だからかば焼きしか見えないんです
生きている生き物やと
その場合は味に執着していて
そうやって考える時でもね
いろんなアイデア いややら気持ちに執着していますよ
例えば怒っても 何ですぐ消えないんですかね
怒りに執着しているんです
だから さらにさらに考えて怒るんです
あの気持ちはもう一度と
面白いことは 怒り 嫉妬
嫌なんですけど 執着しているんですよ
一旦嫉妬が生まれたら消えないんですよ
気持ち悪いのに 思い出しては嫉妬する
思い出しては嫉妬する
だから 自分の子供の写真をね
ポケットに入れて時々見て楽しがっていることとまるっきり同じなんです
だから我々は胃に入る情報にも執着する
今日はちょっと一つ勉強してください
この体に目に入ることは色や形でわかりますね
耳には音ですから これもわかります
胃に何が入るのかということですね
問題は 仏教ではたくさんものが入るんだから
法という言葉を使ってますね
色声香味触法 この法っていうのは仏法の法ではないんです
パーリ語で同じ言葉 ダンマ
ダンマっていう場合は
ただ単に大雑把で物事という意味なんです
この場合は物事ということは何でも入りますね
物事といえば 物事では入らないものは何もないでしょ
そういうわけで 意で何でも考えられます
だって意でウルトラマンのことも考えちゃうでしょ
怪獣のことも いるわけでもないのに
意では何でもできます
ですから 法ですね 意の対象は物事
例えばウルトラマンは
私はウルトラマンと言うんであれは間違いですね
カタカナ発音しないとね
で わしの頭おかしいんで
ウルトラマンって言ってよくわからないんですね
それで自分勝手に英訳するんですね
そうすると ULTR アルトラと思いますけどね
これも間違いなんです
とにかくそこをやめて
まあウルトラでしたっけ
で ウルトラマンに執着するでしょ
子供たちが ウルトラマンが現れた時の男たちは
今はもうもういい加減な大人ですけど
いまだにウルトラマンは好きなんです
もう 30歳 35歳なのに
どうやってありともしないものに執着を送れますかね
送りますよ これ至って簡単に
で 子供の時 ウルトラマンのアニメーションを見てもう感動しました
それでこの気持ちはもう一度ということで執着を作るんです
それでいつだってあの気持ちを作れます
はい それは第1の執着です
カームパーダーナというんです
欲 執着 欲愛 執着ですね
2番目ディットパーダーナ
これカタカナにしようかなと思ったんですけど
なかなかカタカナにならないんだから放っておいたんです
ディットパーダーナ ディッティという言葉とウパーダーナという言葉をつなげてディットパーダーナというんです
ディッティとは見解 意見
思考です 思考 概念などに感情が割り込んでいると見解になります
変えられないんです あの思考そのものが
別にどうってことないんで
まあ起こるものだからね
思考そのものに執着することは大事なんですね
カームパーダーナなんですね
この場合はもうちょっとニュアンスが変わっちゃうんですね
例えば怒りで 欲で 感情で
嫉妬で いろんな感情によって考えること
研究すること 調べること
本を読むこと それで頭の中で見解が生まれてくるんです
これはなかなか変えられません
うーん たとえ我々はどちらかというと宗教がないか
仏教的かという もう中途半端な精神でしょ
皆様もこの中途半端な皆様のところに
もうすごい原理主義のイスラム教の人が来て
ギャーギャーギャーイスラム教になってくださいとかね
それこそ唯一の宗教であるととか何とかと言っちゃうと
うるさいこいつはと なんかいくら喋ってもなかなか乗り気乗る気にはならないんですね
ということは 自分たちがすごい頭が良くて
イスラム教の方言っていることを間違ってる知ってるからではないんです
ほとんどわからないんで
何言ってるのかとか 本当にわかってはないんだけど
もうもうちゃんと女性はね
もう真っ黒い袋を被って生活しなくちゃいけないんだとかね
あれやこれやと言われると
もう放っておいてくださいとという気持ちになっちゃうんだよね
その場合は 皆様方は日本で長い間育てられて
日本文化 日本感覚 日本気持ちによって現れてきた思考があって
それが執着なんですね
だからまるっきり外国文化から来て何か言ったっても聞き入れません
乗る気にならない あの乗る気にさせないことも執着なんです
あの政治家の場合は すごい好みでいろいろ裏心の中いろいろあるかもしれませんだけど
いろんな派閥ができちゃって
その派閥にぐるくる組んでいるでしょ
だから自分たちは何か利益あるでしょうね
そこで その自分の派閥に対して他の人々がいろいろ言っても
耳には入りません ただ
大沢さんのグループの方々に
いくら大沢さん批判したっても
怒られるだけで 聞いてくれない
ちゃんとしたデータを持って
こういうわけで こういう大沢さんを批判するのは日本人の何か趣味みたいで
何も理由がないんです
人を批判するという場合は
ちゃんと証拠を出してデータを出してやらないと情けないし
あれは罪なんです 批判することは罪じゃないんです
批判することで我々の社会がどんどん改良していくんです
根拠のないことで批判するのは
あれは罪なんです  それは置いておいて
で 大沢さんのグループの方々に
いくら我々大沢さん批判をしても
ちゃんと資料データを持っていても
開けてみたっても読んでも入らないんです
その代わりに頭がどうやって大沢先生を弁解するのかという方向
方向へ働いてしまいますね
あの昔のね オウム真理教に入った人々はね
一人も直すことはできないんです
あれはまあ洗脳されて脳細胞が壊れたという判断能力のセクションがね
全部切断されているということもありますけど
一番最近解放された方はね
毎朝ちゃんと拝んでいるんだからね
もう警察の ちゃんと結跏趺坐して瞑想する
そう瞑想する そんな何かやってるみたいんですけど
で そこまでまあここまで犯罪者なのにね
宗教じゃなくて どんな人間の考え方から見てもね
人殺すはいいわけないでしょ
でもこれ入らないんです
サリンを作ったこと悪いとかわからない
人を殺したこと悪いとかわからない
何が悪いんですかと 私はもう
何でしたっけ？存じに頼まれて運んだだけでしょうにと
言ったいでとるでしょ
皆様もおかしいと思うでしょ？おかしくないんです
彼らにはこの見解という執着があって
これでどうにもならんです
もう頭に何言ったっても入らないんです
自分の見解に合うデータしか通らないんです
例えば 人類作った絶対的な神が実際にいるんだそうと
すごく信仰したら これっておかしいんじゃない？と言っただけで
何言うのかと 神を冒涜してということになっちゃうんです
だから私は一つのこういうに喋ってる言葉の中でね
もう1万分の1でも十分ですよ
イスラム教の人に言ったらもう殺されますよ
だから彼の頭には入りません
あの件 この見解という執着で抑えられているんですね
だから見解といえば 全然善も悪もでない普通な言葉なんですよ
見解っていうのは 我々の一般日本語にすれば
アイディア意見 考えですよ
何かアイディアがあって何が悪いんですかね
何か意見があって何が悪いの？全然何も悪くないんですよ
いろいろアイディアがあって
全然何も悪くない いろんな見解があって
何にも悪くないんです
これ普通です 人間なら
では見解執着になってくると
その時感情が入ってるんです
特に貪瞋痴 感情 感情は 3つですけど
貪瞋痴というでしょ 見解の場合は 4つにするんですよ
チャンダドーサバイモーハという
チャンダっていうのは好み
ドーサっていうのは教育
恐怖感 チャンダドーサ
ドーサというのは怒り
嫌な気持ち チャンダは好み
ドーサは怒り 映えは恐怖感
怖い モーハは無知 だから怒り
貪瞋痴の怒りを 2つに分けているんです
分けて 4つにしているんです
だから そういうのを仏教は精密な心理学ですから
そういう風にも 場によっていろいろなことをするんです
まとめて怒りっ子にする場合もあるし
さっと分解して別々にする場合もあります
それで我々の見解 見解がね
何の悪 何の悪くもない見解が
あの貪瞋痴が入り込み入り込んだら見解執着なんです
世の中はほとんどこの知識人ないんですよ
理性の悪い人間いないんです
あの勉強する連中はいるんだけど
自分の知識と一緒に感情が入ってるんですよ
だからもう全然ものすごい問題なんですよ
まあ原発例なんですけど
まあ原発の場合はもう事故起こしちゃって
そこでその原子力関係の人々は
あなた方一般人よりはね
我々は特定の能力ある
特定の技術を学んでいる
世界にある原子力科学者の中でのトップランクの人々であると
調子に乗っちゃったんです
その感情だけ振らすんですよ
世界一 世界一やと これ科学者言うことじゃないでしょ
世界一世界一と バカかホームレスの言葉なの？そんなのは
それで世界一やと言うんじゃ
言う必要ないでしょ 証拠を示せればそれで十分でしょ
私たちは科学者がデータ出したら
そのデータを読んですごいなと思うだけだから
データもなく何も言わないで
俺は世界で科学者だよと言ったら
病院に行きなさいと言うんです
それであの方々は この自分のちゃんと大学で学んだ
それから研究施設で学んだ知識は
自我という感情と混ぜるんです
混ぜたら役に立たない代物になるんです
だからいまだに福島原発はどうなっているかと誰もわからない
研究してもわからない
調べてもわからない もう廃炉にしなくちゃあかんというのは
随分時間経ってから決めるんですよ
原発は破壊した瞬間で
私みたいな何も科学を知らないアホのアホ坊主だって
私はあれはディーコミッションしなくちゃあかんでしょうと言って
ある人にね なんであの人々はサーッとあれで水をかけていきなり抑えておかないのかと
あ もしかするとまたあの修理して使えるだろうと思っているんだと
すると あ なるほど この連中には何も見えないんだと
例えば海水なんかはもう入れちゃいかんとかね
あれはまたすごい計画でしたからね
一旦海水が流したら もうまた二度と使えないんです
だから ちょっと何か中でちょっと爆発したら
ちょっと割れ目が入ったら
この原子炉っていうのはもう使えないんです
永久的に あれ取り外して別なに入れるとか
それは無理です だったらそれはディーコミッション
ディーコミッションで何でしたっけ？はい
廃炉です  廃炉にするべきとすぐ決めればいいでしょう
1時間以内で それからその方向へ働けば
もう準備も終わって半分ぐらい終わっていると思いますよ
まだ始めてもないんです
あと10年ぐらい 日本の国をね
放射線で汚染してからやるでしょう
だからなんでそこまで遅いんですかね
あの原発事故は別に私は誰に悪口言いたくないんで
あれは誰もやったことではないんだからね
しかし 処理するのは人間なんですね
これ 専門家やらなくちゃあかんでしょ
その専門家がなんで専門家になんでできないかというと
やっぱり自我の感情が割り込んでいるんですね
そうするとアイデアが出てこない
あ 困った困った 困ったとかね
まだデータが取られてないとかね
何言うんですかね データが取られていたら取れよと言いたいんだけど
じゃあ これは皆さんに関心があるんだから
例に出したんだけど 関心あるんですかね
勝手に決めた関心あるだろうと
関心なさそうですけど
で 関心ある問題なんですけど
やっぱりこの関係ある人々はテキパキと動いてくれないんですね
これは外国のことは知らんだから忘れておいて
日本のことだけで理解しましょう
これ日本でよくあるでしょ
もう政治家もテキパキと動かないんですね
国会で法律を作る時でも
7  8年かかるんですよ
で それでもう意味がないんですね
あの子供が大津なんとか地方でね
自殺しちゃったんですね
だから これはもういじめ
あまりにもいじめた上で死んだということははっきりしていますけど
いじめも原因で になったと思いますと
これ 1ヶ月間経ってからなんです
あんな連中に皆様は子供を任せているんです
では 専門家といえば私が専門家じゃないんです
その方々はちゃんと教育の専門家で
子供を育てる責任者で
プロでちゃんと訓練も教育も受けています
があの様なんです で 外からみんなこれギャーギャーと言ったんだから
政府は微妙に腰を上げたところで
まあ警察で行って これは犯罪として見なくちゃと調べたから
まあ警察に調べるんだから
やむを得ず まあとりあえずいやいやで
いじめももしかすると原因であったかもしれませんと
いわゆる自殺の直接原因はいじめだという証拠はないんだって
これは私たちもそう思いますよ
いじめたそのまま死んだということないんだからね
いじめっていうのは原子爆弾みたいなもんじゃないんだからね
例えば何か猛毒の薬とか
それだったら飲ませた
死んだなんですよ だからいじめられた
死んだ それじゃないでしょうに
いじめられた結果で子供が飛び降りたんだからね
こいつらは この方々が言いたがっているのは
飛び降りて死んだでしょうにと
飛び降りたことは自分の判断でしょうにと
自分が飛び降りると思ったことは
自分に精神的な問題があったことでしょうにと
長い長い原因を探せば
自分もしかするとひとつちっぽっとの原因であったかもしれませんという態度なんです
これでいいんですかね
この社会から片っ端からね
いじめを取り消さなくちゃあかんでしょ
いじめがあるということは
こと自体が人間じゃない
もう原始猿ということでしょう
よくそれで世界一の大国家と威張ること
世界一大国家じゃなくても
猿もより以下原始人なんですね
いわゆる猿人なんですよ
だからそれは恥ずかしく思って
世界一大国家だからね
世界の大国だから もうきれいさっぱり自分を取り消さなくちゃあかんやと活動しなくちゃいけないところ
この様なんです いじめっていうのは情けないんでしょうし
人はそれぞれ違うということを我々は理解するべきでしょうに
文化的な人間として 黒い服着る来る人もいるし
赤い服着る人もいるでしょうに
なんで黒い服着る人が赤い服着る人をいじめるんですかね
猿人でしょ それだったら
猿ならそんなことやりますよ
だからいじめ自体は我々は精神的に進化していないという証拠なんですよ
それはさっさと取り除かなくちゃあかんでしょうに
なのにこの様 すーっと私が日本に来たその日からのそのいじめの話
よく聞きますよ 自殺したんですよ
この子供だけじゃないんですよ
どれほど子供が自殺したんですかね
いまだに何もやってないんです
だから子供のこと 本当に愛してるんですかね
子供が亡くなったら国がないでしょうに
子供っていうのは国の命であって
魂であって未来でしょうに
国の呼吸でしょうに 子供が亡くなかったら呼吸がない国なんです
すると死んじゃいます
今まあ死にかけてますからね
だから私はお経をあげます
もうあえて般若心経をあげます
あれは嘘の経典だから
パーリ経典ではなくて
まあそれは冗談で言ったんですけど
まあそれで私は言いたいポイントはそういう政治論ではないんです
私に関係ない管轄外のことで
例に出したのは 知識人の知識が感情割り込むとどんなものに変身するのかっていうことです
もったいないでしょ 苦労して学んだ
それからみんなに勉強できるわけないでしょ
勉強できる人々が一生懸命勉強して
そういう高い地位になっているでしょうに
しかし 役に立たない 理由は知識に感情が入っちゃったんです
そうすると見解ではなくて見解執着なんです
だからこれが別な項目でしょ
あの子供の写真ビデオを持っていることは執着だと思ったら
それだけじゃないんです
見解執着 これになりますよ
これはすごい執着なんです
よく気をつけてください
皆様方もいろんなことを勉強し
勉強なさっているでしょうに
知識人でしょうに しかし
この知識人の力発揮できません
執着になると いくらでもアイデアが出ますよ
執着捨てると 科学研究する人ならいくらでも発明できます
しかし 科学研究する若者たちはものすごい地獄の苦しみを味わってますよ
何か何か 何か答えが出てこなくて
何か新しいもの 何か理論をね
出さないと それ出すためにすごい苦労するんですよ
そんな苦労しなくても
あの自我を捨てれば 愛着捨てれば
一緒に研究する人々に対するライバル意識を捨てれば
頭がいくらでもアイデアの
もう何て言いますかね
出るは出るは限りなく出るんです
ですから 人間は本当に知識のおかげで
動物よりはなんとなくマシな生活をしているようですね
動物は礼法使いませんだからね
だからまあ一応我々は動物よりマシな生活をしている
これは知識の結果なんですね
いわゆる科学やらいろいろな知識の結果でしょうに
しかし あんまり役に立ってないんですね
科学も知識も あの最近のあのオスプレイの問題がありましてね
あの あの どこでしたっけ？岩
何県でしたっけ？山口県
そこで県庁が裏切れたとかね
まあ沖縄はダメやとかね
まずはいい加減なことを言うな
アメリカ軍隊はいてほしいんだけど
オスプレイ持ってくるなと
そんないい加減な話成り立ちませんだからね
だから口でご飯とまた両方体から出るもの全部入れるんじゃないんで
一緒にはっきりしないと
そこははっきりしていない
アメリカ軍隊入れませんと言えば
それで話終わりでしょうに
それはしない しかし あれを持ってくるな
これを持ってくるな こちらにいるな
どこかに行けとか それで日本国民はこちらに来るな
こちらに来るなと では軍隊
日本のアメリカとの友情関係は大事
でも来るなよと なんだかよくわからない
私は はい それは置いておいて
オスプレイという飛行機がね
もう安全は確認していないんだと
あの軍事のものっていうのは一つも安全性確認してないんですよ
何一つも だって使うのは軍人だから
軍人が死んじゃっても
軍人のことを人間扱いしないんです
荷物です 戦争に使う 軍事活動という独裁組織のいろいろ歯車だけで
そんなにもないんです
だから何人か死んじゃったら
それそれでまずいやと
あの人が死んだことではなくて
この飛行機が落ちたらすごい損するでしょ
だからもうちょっと訂正しましょうと
直しましょうということになるんであって
それは軍事世界 いつでもそういう考えの人
人の命を大事にしましょうと
軍事活動しようと一緒にならないことだからね
それでも置いておいて
次のポイントに私が気になっているのは
科学者たちが新しい飛行機を設計したんですね
ヘリのようでヘリではありませんと
飛行機のようで飛行機ではありません
両方機能しているんだと
それは何に使うかというと
どこででも簡単に着陸して人を殺して
またそこから滑走路もなく出て行けるんだと
あれは人を殺すための道具なんです
だから皆様にも 北海道ではなくて
そこら辺 例えばオスプレイがね
民間用に使えば あちらこちらで行けるでしょう
空港がなくても もう羽田に行かなくても
ここら辺でどこかで じゃあ代々木公園に集合しましょうと
そこから飛行機に乗ってどこかに行くとかね
できますよ でもあれにはだいたい 30年ぐらいかかると思います
そこまで人殺しに使う
だから科学はそうやって役に立ってないんです
人殺しに使うという これどう考えてもおかしいでしょう
私は人殺しの研究をしていますよと
なんで正直に言わないんですかね
まあみんな嘘つきということは本当に得意なんですよ
だから自分を騙せます
私はロケットの研究をしていますよと言い張るんです
本当は人殺しの研究をしているんです
だから一番世の中でね
人類の中で何億人もいるんです
一番性格悪いのは私だけかもしれません
私は全部もう嘘を抜けて本当のことを言うんです
あれはただの人殺しの研究
人殺しの機械開発 で で
役に立ってない 他の面で考えれば
ここまで知識人がいて
これものすごい天才たちがいて
ものすごい発明できる人間がいて
なんでこの世界はと なんで息苦しいのかと
なんで金がないのかと
なんで家賃が払わなくなっちゃったところでホームレスにならなくちゃいけないのかと
なんで治療代払えないのかと
おかしいでしょうに そのおかしさを生んだのは
知識が執着になっているからなんです
見解執着になっているんです
人のために使うんじゃなくて
人を殺すために使う 威張るために使う
北朝鮮にしたっても 大金は全部このミサイルと軍事に活動に使う
軍事大国家作れそうと
一般人はいるという感じですね
ネズミですね 一般人は
なぜそこまで信じられないほど人類がおかしいんですよ
例えば私は慈悲の瞑想を紹介したところで言われたこと
気持ち悪いやと そんなのはと
堂々と言ったんだから
そんなことを面と向かって言っちゃうと
これすごいいじめでしょ
ものすごいサービスされましたよ
だから私を見て学んでください
差別されると いじめるとどんな態度をとるのかと
自殺するのかと 何の丁重もなく殺める
変な批判すればするほど
こちらはどんどんパワーアップする
あんたこの間講演でこういう言葉言った
これはおかしいよ はい
わかりわかりましたと
今度は10回 だからまあ
我々人間っていうのは本当に桁違い
おかしいんですよ だから残念なこと
みんなバカじゃないんですよ
バカでもアホでもないんで
ちゃんと教育を受けてるんです
ちゃんと研究して論文も出してるんです
が なんでこの様やといったら
この見解に貪瞋痴が入ってるんですね
自我やら怒りやら競争心やら好みやら
いろんなものが入ってるんです
あの国会議論聞いてみてください
なんかこの人々 頭おかしいんじゃないかなと思うぐらいおかしいことを言うんですね
議論できないんじゃないかな
できますよ あの方々に
頭おかしいわけじゃないんです
ちゃんと勉強しています
が なんであんな程度というと
やっぱり好み 自分の党を守らなくちゃあかん
次は自分たちで政権を取ってボロ儲けしなくちゃあかん
だからそこを入ってくると
喋ってるものは全部ちんぷんかんぷんになってくるんです
そういうことで この国会で何一つも通させてくれないわ
いろいろでしょ そういう風にどんなところを見ても
親と子の関係でしたっても
お母さんたちが結構勉強していますよ
私は自分の国から来てね
もう日本の子供たちっていうのはとんでもない羨ましいやつらだと思ったんですよ
だって ちゃんとした知識人の母親たちに育てられているんだから
ほとんどの母親たちはちゃんと大学を出ているんです
こんなもう大学も出ていて
そんなに知識のある母親に育てられると
この子供たちは怖いだろうと
大きくなってくると 本当に怖いんです
で 私が言った意味の怖いじゃないんです
私は期待した怖い子供ではなかったんです
だからなんで 例えば私のお母さんがちょっと何か読めただけなんですよ
一度でも私の学校の本を開けて教えてくれたこと
宿題一回でも見てもらったことはないんです
それと比較してください
日本人を育てるお母さんはどんな程度かと
ものすごい知識人たちでしょうね
それでゾウアサリを育てるんです
何の芸もできない 猿素材なら猿にも芸できますけどね
ゾウアサリ食わせてあげたって
ドカーンと転がってるだけだからね
死亡ばっかり黙って で
やっぱり どこかに問題があるんですよ
これ どこかではなくて
これは執着の問題なんですね
大学で学んだ知識があるんだけど
そちらに感情が入っているんです
それで終わり 役に立ちません
だから見解執着ということは
我々現代世界ではよく勉強した方がいいんです
もし力発揮したければ
バンバンアイデアを出したければ
日本は今経済的に鈍足なんですけど
もう一度先頭に立ちたければ
もう一度経済大国になりたいと思うならば
世界を驚かせちゃえと思うならば
見解があっても見解執着はなくすことなんです
だって簡単ですけどね
感情はチャンダドーサバヤモーハですね
貪瞋痴は 4つに分けています
これは説明しました 自分の見解が正しく
他人の見解は間違っていると思われる気持ち
これで理解できると思いますよ
自分が言っていることは正しいでしょう
一応 あれがまずいんですよ
あれが執着があるという意味なんです
自分が意見を言っても
相手の意見を聞いたところで
あら 私の私が間違っていたと気づいたら執着ないんですよ
あら 俺が間違ったな それで話終わりでしょ
新しい正しい見解が入ったんです
しかし 自分が言っていることは正しいという気持ちがあったら
相手が言っていることに腹が立つんです
正しいかもしれませんだけど
腹が立ってます 時々そう言うでしょ
あなた言うこと正しいかもしれませんだけど
出て行ってくださいと
ああいう風な言う時は明確に執着の病にかかっているんです
執着の病にかかったら
もう人間ではありません
ただの生き物です その気持ちは執着になりますね
はい  2番目ディットゥーパダーナ
見解執着 これ 1項目で講義 1つになりますけどね
これ全部説明する時間ないんです
はい  3番目シーラッブトゥーパダーナ
あの戒律 行 儀式 儀礼などに対する執着
これは耳が痛くないんですね
説明しましょうか  2番目はかなり耳が痛いと思います
痛かったと思いますけど
3番目はこの戒律行とかね
皆さんも戒律と聞いただけで嫌でしょ？執着するわけないでしょ
道徳を守る言っただけで嫌でしょ
執着するところじゃないんですね
だから説明聞かないことにしましょうか
あの道徳を守ることとは違います
それが 特に宗教の世界で語る行儀作法
儀式 苦行などです あの嘘をつかないで
人を騙さないで 真面目に生きていることはダメっていうわけじゃないんです
それは道徳でしょ 当たり前でしょ
人間なら 文化的な人間なら嘘をつかないのは当たり前でしょう
人のものを奪わないのは当たり前でしょうに
金が欲しければ仕事をするのは当たり前でしょう
それが道徳なんです こちらでいう戒律っていうのは
このいろいろ宗教で言ってるでしょ
皆様は宗教に行かなくても占い師のところに行くでしょ？行かない
行ってください で 占い師のところに行ったら
まあいろいろなところに行ったら
いろんなこと言われるでしょ
こうやってください ああやってくださいとかね
昔は統一教会が流行っていた時はね
もう私も結構批判を受けましたけど
日本人に あれぐらい素晴らしい宗教あるのに
なんであなたは と 今聞きたい
どこですかね あの宗教はとか
同じこと言われたんでしょ
往信旅行の場合も 悟っている人がいるのにとかね
それからあの頭イカれてる人がいるでしょ
オカルトという ブッダがいるのに
あなたは何やと あの大使館でこの国家の独立記念日の挨拶で
私は参加 私は正式に坊主で参加してるんだから
仕事になるんですよ ふざけてる場合じゃないんです
ちゃんと決まってる 二
三分でそのいろいろしきたり
いろいろやって祝福して
国にも馬鹿どもたちにもさっさと帰らなくちゃあかんですよ
これで来て あんたね 今ブッダがいるんだからとかね
だからそういうその宗教はまだ生きてますけどね
他の宗教はどうか どこにいるのかと聞きたいところなんですけど
まあとにかくその統一教会の時は壺を買わせるんでしょうに
大体値段はまあ 1,500円の壺を作って
100万円で売ってるんです
買わなきゃ罰が当たるんだぞと
買わなきゃ あのし 何れ指令じゃなくて
ご先祖様に恨まれるぞとかね
霊の怨念があるぞとかね
あれやこれやとか言われるんです
それで何のことなく 100万円出して
時々 5,000万出してる人もいて 1,000
万出した人々は騙されたと裁判もかけましたけどね
これは大事にどこかに床の間に置いておいて
朝から朝も晩もお礼をすると
あんなのはなんです ああいうことを信仰すること
それが大事だと思うことは開眼症なんです
執着している とらわれているんです
やめたらやばいと思ってるんです
特にどんな宗教でもいろんな儀式を教えるんです
私は般若心経に対して本を出したところで
一人も私の内容を批判しなかったんですね
あなたの理論は間違っているとか
あんたこういうこういう適当に参考にしてないんだとかね
いうことは日本で一人もいないんです
般若心経を学んだ人は
一応私も本を書いたりする場合は
いくらか弱いところを残しておくんですよ
攻撃するならば ここら辺から来いと
結構結構残しておく 大体本を一つになってくると
まあまあ 10箇所から 20箇所ぐらいあると思います
隙間があるところ 編集するってくるな
それでいいやと 私はすごい怒って
それでいいや やめたと
いうのは そこ穴を置いておいたんです
発見せなさいと 誰も発見しないしね
それは置いておいて だから般若心経を間違っていると言った言葉に腹が立っているだけ
あれが回文集なんですね
これがギャーギャーと言ってね
あの悪霊払いする大事なお経でしょ
だからみんなにこの神秘的な力のある
なんかご利益をバンバン売ってくる
商売繁盛はもうズルズルが起こる
大変なパワーなんですよ
これが間違えちゃったら
もういても立ってもいられなく
いられなくなりますね
中身はどうでもいいんです
読んでもないんです 私の本を読んでないのはいいんだけど
般若心経ぐらい読めと
読んでないんです 暗記したら読んでいると思ってるんです
暗記することと読むことは違いますけど
はい そういうことで そのケース出しても
この回向衆なんですね
儀式にとらわれている
しきたりにとらわれている
このしきたりやめたら
おお やばいと  100年もやってきたんだから
あんた何言うのかと それから山の木をね
一つと切って 地面に落ちないように気をつけて下ろして
あの白い布で覆って それからロープでね
あのわらのね あれで巻いて
それからよっこらしょいと運んで
汚れないように持ってきますね
神社まで なんだかあれはただの木でしょう
トラックに運んだ方が早くない？やらないんです
御神体だから 御神体で御神木ですからね
それで御神体 御神木っていう言葉が入ると回向衆なんです
もうどうにもならんよ
何も私が言ってもいいんだけど
皆さんに言わないでくださいよ
失礼ですよ 時々山の上で木を切って
これは山の上からずっと下まで落とす場合もあり
あれで上に乗らなくちゃあかんね
人々は どこで救急車ずっと並んでいるんですね
この国でね 仏教は立ち入り禁止と言っているこの国で
あれは禁止すればいいでしょうに
怪我したら困りますよと
禁止するところじゃなくて
救急車ちゃんと法律的に見たってもね
あのものすごい勢いで落ちる
あの木に乗るなよと 乗せなさいと言ったら
法律違反でしょ でも警察はちゃんと警備して待っているんです
危ないんだから近寄るなよとかね
あちらで人死んでますけどね
だからなんであの仕来りをやめられないかというと
あれは回向衆なんです
昔からやってるんだからと
だからいつどんなわけで誰が始めたかというとないんですね
それで何か物語るんですね
なんだらかんだら 神がなんだらかんだらなところ
なんだらかんだらなりましたと
これは神話物語りでしょう
ですから あの回向衆っていうのは嘘をつくなよという戒律じゃないんです
結局は皆様みんな持ってるんです
我々誰でも人間ならね
回向衆は持ってます 執着は人間にみんなにあります
あえて日本人悪いって意味じゃなくて
人間なら誰にでも回向衆はあります
あの苦行が一つ どんな国でも面白いこと
苦行好きなんです アメリカ人もやっちゃいますからね
皆様使っている APPLE 製品の会社の社長がね
あれ えらい苦行中毒でしたからね
わけのわからないバカなんですよ
ただ苦行したくたまらないと
断食したくてたまらないと
だから断食しないで もうもう肉ばっかし食って酒飲んでる仲間たちがみんなバカやと
でも長生きはしています
しているんですけど ジョブさんよりは
そういう風に どんな国にどんな人にでも
人間なら回向衆 何か苦行好きということはあるんです
そこで宗教を新しく工場で作る時ね
宗教というのは工場で作るんです
あの人間 誰かがグループを集めて
隠れて考えて作るもんでしょ
宗教っていうのは だからわからないんだったら本を読んでみてください
いくらでもありますからね
で 何か 例えばこの幸福の科学という人が
この霊言なんとかっていう本を出していたんですね
霊言っていうんでしたっけ
霊言 いろんな歴史的な人物の名前に乗って
何々道元の道元じゃなくて
親鸞の霊験 日蓮の霊験とか
いろいろね いい加減なことを言うんですね
だからいい加減なことを言うんだから
誰かの霊験と言った方が安心なんですね
それを読んだら こいつは結構ずるがすごいなと私は思ったんですね
それから自分がブッダになりあがっちゃって
ブッダになりあがったところで
このブッダは修行して悟ったっていう話をどこかから聞いたんですよ
それでいきなりある本で
後ろに何でか何歳で大悟を得まったと書いてある
ある日突然 だったら最初の本でもそれ書いとけばよかったのに
そんなもんです 宗教を作る場合はね
必要なことを後から考えて入れたりする
じゃあ悟ったことにしましょうかと
それ皆様を馬鹿にする
だからそこはポイントで
まああの仏教なんかの場合はね
やっぱり苦行が必要なんですね
それで皆様に馴染みのあるキリスト教の場合は
苦行はなさそうに見えるでしょ
苦行は好きですけど やりたくないんですね
そこが問題なんです 苦行は好き
苦行するならば一生懸命がむずの日と
お布施でも金でも何でもあげる
苦行している人からいつでも祝福してほしいんです
苦行のファンですけど
自分ではやらない  それはそれでいいんです
で このキリスト教という宗教が作った場合は
やっぱり苦行が必要なんですね
なぜならば キリスト教に参考にしたユダヤ教ではいけにえがあったんですね
神がいつでも殺せ 殺せ
殺せと言ってるんですね
人間殺してくれないんだったら
動物でも殺してくれと
いけにえにしなさいと
いうふうなことで やっぱりユダヤ教では未だにやっています
動物のいけにえをね で
だからそこって何か苦行みたい
なんか残酷でしょ あれが尊い
ありがたいと 残酷やと思わないでね
我慢するんですね それでキリスト教の場合は作ったんですけど
妄想で宗教一つ キリスト様が自殺しなかったという話もありましてね
私はその話には乗ってるんです
自殺しなかったよと で
何か苦行なくちゃ困るんですね
それで汝なんという考えを作ったんですね
歴史的にローマ帝国では
そんな人を十字架に釘を打って殺したっていうことは全くデータがないし
それで人の国でやる場合は
政治的なすごい犯罪を起こした人々だけしかやらなかったし
まあどこらの馬鹿と馬の骨か知らない人を捕まってね
だって普通の人間 ならばね
十字架にかけるぐらいのそれじゃない
そんな罪を犯ってないでしょうに
しかし そのストーリーを作ったんで
受難する 生贄になる 苦行する
そこで神を信仰する私たちは苦行しなくても
あのチケットでパスで天国に行けるんです
だから この懺悔して洗礼を受けたら天国に行けますし
最後の審判では OK になりますね
それに苦行が必要です
苦行のセクションが代表でやってるんです
そこでそのストーリーを作る時でもね
私に読めるのは そのギリシャにいたユダヤ人の方々はね
まあかなり頭のいい人々でしたけど
あの方々は そのストーリーを作る時も
やっぱり感情的にはやっぱり苦行はいるでしょうよという執着があるんですね
はっきりと回向宗は だからヒンドゥー教も絶対的神を信仰してるでしょ
なんで苦行するんですかね
意味がないでしょ イスラム教の方々も一部はすごい苦行をする
キリスト教の聖職者たちの一部は結構苦行をする
あれ 形の苦行なんですね
これこれ食べないとかね
もうこういうふうな 自分でもう自分で作ったものしか食べないとかね
ものすごいボロ服の装束を着るのとかね
あのあの 東京に住んでいるカトリックの神父様がね
スリランカ 確かにおいるんですけど
このベルトの代わりにロープなんですね
だから 古い東京でね 自分のクロークの上にただの格好悪いロープをつなげているとね
感動しますよ 服もボロボロで
私の気持ちは聞かないでください
そんなものを見ると何感じるのかと
一般人は感動する で 人間っていうのは苦行好きですよ
それから山に登る時は山を拝んで
まあなんとかという感じで守ってくださいとかね
で 我々はあらゆる儀式
例えばね 葬式に行ったら塩をちょこっとかけてもらう
ほんのちょっとでいいんですよ
どんな化け物もあり 怖くてできます
あの魚の場合でも 大量の塩をかけておかないと細菌入りますけどよね
だからこの化け物っていうのは細菌 1個よりも弱いんですよ
魚を保存するときは結構塩をかけて大量の塩をかけないと
細菌が発生して腐っちゃいます
しかし 私たちを怯えている幽霊やら悪霊っていうのは
これぐらいの塩をちゅっと振ったらもうない
だからそういう信仰って何で？これ回向宗なんです
そこでそういうことにボロクソに笑う私は悪人に感じるでしょ
人間のもう 2000年前から 3000年前
4000年前でどちらでもいいんで
いい加減だから 5000年前からでもいいんですけど
もう守ってくるしきたり
習慣はボロクソにバカにすると
それでは何かすごく悪人で感じますね
悪人で感じる時も回向宗なんです
笑えないでしょ それは仏教でないわけじゃないんで
仏教にもありますよ テーラワーダ仏教にもあります
回向宗はないわけないでしょ
だって人間にあることだからね
これなくしてほしい かっこ悪いんですよ
でお坊さんたちもいます
服装で決まってやるぞとかね
これしか着ることできないんだけど
ある特別に手で抜いた衣とかね
あるいは特別に粗い重い衣だけ着て
見る限りこれえらい品質が悪い衣って感じるようなもの
ボサッと感じるものを着て
ゆっくりと下を見てゆっくりと歩くとかね
頑張ってます 私みたいに誰よりも先に歩いてやるぞっていうことはないんです
本当にお坊さんたちが歩くとはものすごくストレスたまるんですよ
ここからあそこまで歩くと
私はもうこの建物から出て道路に行ってるんです
で 私にわからないのは
どうやってあそこまであの片足盛りのやり方で歩けるのかと
そういういろんなことに
どんな意味もないことにね
執着して慣れて それで一般の方々の感動を受けます
今 日本ではね お坊さんたちはね
この儀式に合わせて服装
衣装を変えるでしょ まあもう歌舞伎じゃないんだから
同じ黒でいいのに 普通の黒いね
ある法被というね あれでもいいんだけどね
何か首に一つ こちら一つ
あちら一つ こっち やっぱりあれがなければ雰囲気が出ないんです
あの葬式に参加する方々も怒りますよ
普段お坊さん 普段着ているあの青い色の普通のあの作務衣で来て
あ いいよ じゃあ起き上げますと言ってやっちゃうと帰られませんんです
何言われるかわからないんです
それで特別にアイロンかけて
スターチのりをかけて
それも着て こちらのコラーがあって
こちらに何かあって また首にかけるもの
ここにあってかけるもの
いろいろ道具があって
特別にでっかいお数珠があってとか
そういうおしゃれで行くんですね
このおしゃれ自体が宗教になっているんですね
このおしゃれ自体が葬式法要になっているんですね
回文集です 中身は関係ないんですね
誰も気にしない 中身は
この誰か亡くなったらね
お坊さん頼んでお経を上げてもらいますけど
みんな形式なすことに興味あるんであって
中身はどうでもいいんです
どんなお経上げてもいいんです
例えばね お経の代わりに人民恋愛南法連邦というある中国の雑誌
新聞があるでしょ 誰がお坊さんがその新聞をちょっとちょっと来て
本の間に挟んでね あの漢字を読んでも
みんな合掌して間違いなし
だから中身はあまり気にしないんです
時々 現代のお坊さんたちの中でね
日本語でお経をあげましょうという運動もないわけじゃないんだけど
あれやばいんですよ 私も推薦していますけど
日本語でやっちゃいますよと
やばいんですよ 怒られる可能性あります
だって戒厳集会なくなっちゃうでしょ
みんなにわかるようにお経あげちゃうとまずいですよ
この知識が起きたらね
道徳を守る 守る羽目になったら困るでしょ
だからもう嫌がりますね
そうやってこの新しい教えでもみんなに発表しにくい状態なんです
例えば 今までの仏教のやり方が間違ってあっても
これは間違ってますよと
これから本物をやりますよと言えないんです
あの間違いは直せなくなる状況も回向衆なんです
これ 特に宗教世界にある問題です
皆様方は宗教は持ってないとか威張っても意味がないんです
人間にはやっぱりあるんですよ
この何といいますか レリジアスネスということ
いわゆる宗教的精神はあります
得体知らないものに対しては恐れを感じる
これがない人間がいないんです
キリスト教 仏教 イスラム教
あれやこれや それはないんです
それはいわゆる既定 既定のね
既成宗教はね なくても人間には宗教あるんです
いわゆるまあレリジアスネスよりもレリジオシティという単語が一番正しいんですけど
宗教的な気持ち あるんです
ですから そちらにこのいる
何で何かしらか儀式入ってくるんです
何かしらか何か迷信が入ってくるんです
占いも一つなんですよ
なんでバカは占いに行くんですかね
あんなの嘘や嘘やと言いながら行くんです
あれが生命 人間が本来持っている宗教的感覚の問題なんですね
宗教的感覚があると 迷信が起こり得る
儀式 しきたりは起こり得る
ですから これ心理学なんです
心理学的に見ると 人間に宗教的感覚があります
この宗教的感覚から現れてくる行儀作法がすべてに執着する
それで行儀作法はなくならなくない
なくならないんです 日本社会は毎日変わるんだけど
昔から伝わってきた行儀作法は変わらないんです
儀式は変わらないんです
そこで日本はやられましたからね
西洋に やられる前に日本側から西洋の文化をね
まあ拝んで受け取ったりしたでしょ
これ日本は悪いんです
悪いんだけど 悪いことをちゃんと続けてやっちゃったし
それで西洋はもうアジア人を人間扱いしないし
全部野蛮やと思っているしね
だから強引に自分たちのだらしない文化を入れちゃうんですね
だからこちらでは 日本ではクリスマスやらない日本人はほとんどない
お寺でもやります では
イエスが本当に 12月 25日生まれたんですかね
ないんです 誰も知らない
定年合併は だって作った人物だから
で そこであの我々のあの弱み
あの回向衆があるんだから
なんだかクリスマスの習慣が来たら
これはヨーロッパ人のお祭りだというふうに思わなくなっちゃって
ああ やりたい ありがたいというふうになっちゃうんです
それでそれで気が済まないんだから
ハロウィンもやるし で
また何でしたっけ？ホワイトデーやらね
いろいろやりますね とにかくアホのくだらんことだからもう忘れちゃった
まあいろいろしきたり習慣がありますよ
だからこれはなくならないんですね
だから戒律は嫌というでしょ
あれも回向衆だからなんです
戒律どうとか守るべきもので
クリスチャン人間なら
こちらで言ってるものは喜んでやっているもので
やめてほしいということなんです
やめなさいなんです 仏教は
迷信神話信仰に基づくものです
インドでは裸行 断食 苦行などは救済の方法だと思っていたんですね
で これ お釈迦様によく大きな問題で見えたのは
インドはもう派手にこの回向衆にやられて
心清らかにすることはできなかった
社会現象があったんですよ
宗教家はいっぱいいたのに
一人にも成功できなかったんです
それでお釈迦様がこの心の弱みを発見したんです
データがありすぎでした
回向衆はそれなんですね
はい 最後に来ます 最後の煩悩
アッタワードゥーパーダーナ
我論我説に執着することです
あえて我論我説と書いたんです
私が存在すると信じて執着する
私がいますよ いるんでしょ？私がいますよと言って
それはものすごく信じます
私がいますよと言ったっても
もうちょっと調べて証拠を出せばいいでしょうに
あんたいろんなこと言っていますよと
じゃあ証拠を出してこいと
そしたら あれ あんた頭おかしいと言われるでしょ？おかしくないんだよ
私がいるということには証拠を出した方がいいんです
これは証拠を出す 誰も関係でないんです
だっているもんと言うんですね
私がいるという気持ちがあって
それが我論に発展するんですね
真の自分が変化する肉体の中に潜んで存在しているという考えです
私がいるんだという気持ちはいいんですけど
そこはちょっと発展して
真の自分 この壊れかけている肉体の中に隠れている
潜んでいると信じたら
ガセですで我論 インドではたくさんの我論がありました
ものすごいリストを探そうと思ったら
これは 100飛びますからやめたんです
我論の種類 最大の執着は自分に対する執着です
今は執着ミス説明したでしょ
なんか我論が軽く感じるでしょ
あ 女哲学者じゃないでしょうと
私たちはと 違います これが最大の執着なんです
自分に対する執着 が最大強烈です
どんな悪いことでもしますよ
自分を愛する人は 自分に執着する人は
自分がいると思って自分探しをしています
これは日本である またもう一つ矛盾
だからどこを見ても矛盾だから
私にとっては日本にいることは楽しくてたまらんですよ
あまりにも楽しくなるの
良くないんだから隠れているんです
それで自分がいるとすごいしつこく言ってるくせに
自分探し 自分探し 今忘れちゃったんだけど
もうちょっと何年前でね
大騒ぎのコピープレースでしたからね
ここで私にも講演頼まれたこともありましたからね
自分探しとは何ぞやと教えてくれとかね
だから自分がいるんだったら
なんで探すんですかね
何やってるんですかね
とにかく頭おかしいんですよ
自分ですけど これ真の自分じゃないんだと
真の自分を探さなくちゃあかんやと
だったら地獄まで穴でも掘っちゃえば見つかるでしょうね
ハワイにでも行って飛び込めば
地獄に穴が開いてるでしょ
ハワイで だから何のことやってるんですかね
結局はそれは本人たちが真面目ですよ
自分を探している方々は
真面目に調べて研究したりしますよ
いろんな先生たちの講義も受けますよ
真面目なのはいいんだけど
あれが執着なんです 自分に対する
だからあんな私に笑われるボロクソに言われることをやってるんです
自分がいるんだったら探す必要ないのに
それでこの この自我 我論
我説執着はすべての生命にあります
それであの仏教では明確に初心者にも無我
無我 無我と言ってますよ
でも悟らないんですね
ほとんど 悟れない理由がこの我説なんです
仏教徒なのに ちっちゃい時から仏教環境の中で大きくなったのに
仏教を学んで大きくなったのに
無我のこと 無常のことをずっと教え勉強したのに
四聖諦のことはもう暗記までして勉強したのに
悟らないんです それがまだ甘いんです
自分には本当にこの我論という執着があるんだということは
真面目に心配して考えてないんです
これは私みたいに今喋ってるような口調で
ものすごくはっきりとぶつけた方がいいんです
自分持ってる我説 はい
それで 執着の起源 執着は 4つありました
なんで執着現れますかね
眼耳鼻舌身意に これから省略できます
色声香味触法が触れる
これ前に説明しました
体に情報が触れる 触 パッサによって六感覚組織が起こる
難しくないんです あの目
耳 鼻に情報が触れると感じます
音が耳に触れると感じますね
あれは触れることはパッサというんです
ただの触れることでしょ
なんで専門用語？これは大事だからなんです
これで全部起こるんです
このちょっとした音が耳にぷっと触れることで
それで全部起こります
耳に光の触れただけでいろんなことが起こるんです
だからパッサが触は大事です
で 触れたら感じるんですよ
音を感じる この感じることには
こちらではこの感覚組織と書いたんです
なぜかというと お釈迦様はそういう単語を使っているんです
感じますよと言ったら
もう一般的で 感覚組織っていうのは
耳で感じる時は あれは単純な仕事じゃないんですよ
結構組織的なからくりなんですよ
組織ぐるみで起こるんです
だから感覚組織なんです
神経もいるでしょうし
脳細胞もいるでしょうし
いろいろ温度も関係ありますし
いろんなことがあって
この組織絡みで感覚が生まれる
ですから感覚組織 6あります
目で感覚組織 耳の感覚組織
舌の感覚組織 鼻の感覚組織
体の感覚組織と意の意識の感覚組織 6
あります 感覚によって渇愛が生じる
感じたら欲しいか欲しくないかと
もう起きちゃうんです
耳に入った音は欲しいか
嫌か うるさいかとか もう起きてます
それは渇愛というんです
渇愛によって執着が起こるんです
はい これで我々の大事な
いや あの人が現れてきます
渇愛から執着が起こります
これがあまり一般の方々に理解できない
ものすごい難しいの 心理学的ないろんなところありますけどね
これどうやってごまかすのか
私悩んでますけど 真剣になっちゃうと難しいんですよ
だからふざけてごまかした方がわかりやすいと思います
で こういうことなんですよ
例えば 夏だからね バニラアイスクリームを 1さじをベロに入れる
美味しいでしょうね 冷たいしね
冷たさが体中広がっちゃって
バニラの香りと甘さがベロに広がってくる
まあ気分がいいこと なんでバニラを選んだかというと
私は大嫌いなんです あれはバニラじゃないんです
日本のアイスクリームに入れてる
あれは気持ち悪い お腹が気持ち悪くなる何か化学のものなんです
あのバニラっていうのはものすごくリラックスさせるんですよ
生の本物のバニラはね
で 今度持ってきて持ってきましょうかって約束はできませんだからやめますけど
で 自分のためにも今度はバニラ1本持ってきます
豆は で 本物はね 本当に香りが入ってくると
こういう気分になるんですよ
すごくリラックスするんです
ストレスが消えるんです
それでも日本のバニラアイスクリームを食べると
作った会社まで壊したくなるんです
これは雑談で置いておいて
で 皆様方はね 他のバニラの味を知らないんだからしょうがないでしょ
だからこのバニラアイスクリームを一口ベロに入れたら
もう冷たさが広がって気分がいい
それから甘い香りと甘い味が広がってくると
すごい気持ちがいいな
欲しい 楽しいという気分が生まれる
それは渇愛ですよ しかし
それ食べて終わって水一杯飲むでしょ
またあの味もでもないでしょ
あるいはアイスクリーム食べてから紅茶 1杯飲む
紅茶じゃなくてコーヒー1杯
全く苦みがあってね 違う味でしょ
では バニラソフトクリームの渇愛はどこですかね？もう消えちゃったんです
次やるのはコーヒーに対する渇愛なんです
で コーヒーも飲んでから
なんかちょっと口当たりの味が悪いんだから
水 1杯飲む それで残るのは水の味なんです
もうバニラの味はもう知らん
もうわからない もう出ていってるんです
そんな感じで 渇愛はポツンポツンと現れて消えるもんなんですよ
ご飯食べるとご飯 口に入れたら一つの渇愛
たくあん 1枚を噛むと別な渇愛なんです
味によって別々な渇愛が生まれていくんです
まあ全部欲ですけどね
美味しいという しかし
渇愛として別なんです
それがなんで執着になるかというと
どこかであの粘着剤がね
この楽しみはもう一度というあれが生まれるんです
例えばヘーゲンデーズですという
ヘーゲンダズでしたっけ？会社のアイスクリーム食べたら美味しかったならば覚えておきます
ヘーゲンダズと 今度からレディーボーンではなくて
ヘーゲンダズ食ってやるぞと
それが渇愛執着です だから欲がその場で消えるんですよ
どこかの店で天ぷら食べたら
初めはなんかちょっとどうかな
この店はなんか 1,000円 2,000円高いでしょ
他の店よりは とかね いろいろ文句もあったんだけど
やっぱり 3,000円も払って
普通の店なら 1,000円の天ぷら食べちゃったんです
食べたところでなんかやけに違う
揚げ方が違う 感触が違う
香りが違う 口の中で天ぷらを噛む時
あの醤油に入れたのにも関わらず
感触がよろしいしね カリッとしたこと
醤油でなくならないんですね
そういうかなり腕を振った天ぷらなんですね
これで店の名前覚えちゃいます
覚えてみんなに言いふらしちゃうんです
だから口コミ情報という世界迷惑は日本の社会現象なんです
あれ 口コミ情報ほど社会迷惑はないんです
本当に嘘ですからね 口コミで伝えるのは
はい そういうことで もうもうこの冗談の話ですけど
笑いながらこの心理学を覚えてください
で 天ぷら食べると美味しいでしょうに
まじな話で美味しいんだったら好きでしょうに
だから美味しいことには欲と渇愛は生まれますね
気持ち悪いと思えないでしょ
好きに執着が生まれるんです
執着が この味はもう一度という仕事を作っちゃうんです
この味はもう一度味わいたいんだけど
しかし金がない ということで
金が貯まったらまた行きますと店の名前を覚えておく
だから明確に心理学的に渇愛から執着が生まれる
例えばこの講演会の中に
なんかちょっとしたやんちゃの男の子供がいたとしましょう
こいつもやんちゃでザーッと走っていこうとしたら
まあみんな可愛いなという感じで見てるんですけど
誰かの足にドッカンとぶつかっちゃう
これで激怒 だからといって子供にこらあれやこれと言えないでしょ
我慢する そこで感覚が生まれたね
これは激怒でしたから
嫌な嫌な気持ちが生まれた
それ渇愛です 渇愛というのは必ずしも欲っていうわけじゃないんです
嫌な気持ちが生まれた
嫌だ これ痛いなっていうかね
それ渇愛 次に執着生まれてるんですよ
もう一回 その男の子があちらで走ってきて
ここのすぐもうもうビクビクしてるんです
もう足を中に入れちゃって
気をつけているんです
ぶつからないようにと
あの感覚は二度とは嫌やと
あれが執着が起こすんです
でなきゃ ぶつけたら痛かった
終わった 終わりです 痛みは消えます
これ 痛みに執着が入ると
子供が見る時でも痛くなってくるんです
子供はこちらを見ると
あちらから 行こうかなと思いますね
そういう経験私もいろいろあります
いるなと思ったら そこら辺ではなくて
別な道で行くんです そこがあの執着の起源なんです
至って簡単でしょ 眼耳鼻舌身に情報が触れる
すると感覚が触れる 感覚が生まれる
感覚の次 渇愛が生まれる
渇愛に執着が生まれる
本当のところ面白いんですよ
この花もう一度見たいではないんです
我々は この映画をもう一度見たいじゃないんです
同じ映画を 2回見ると面白くないんです
その映画を見た時 心に現れたあの気持ちを何回も再現してほしいんです
だから あの映画はもう一回見たいと思っちゃうんです
何回も再現してほしいと思うところが執着なんです
だから本当に我々はね
外国旅行する時でも 毎日同じなものを見たくはないでしょう
何年行ってもハイパーク公園は同じやと
だったら面白くないんですよ
もしイギリスのハイパーク公園は週ごとにものすごい変わるならば
行くたびにビクビクするんですよ
今度はどんなものかと
だから我々はこの同じものを繰り返して見たがっているわけじゃないんです
同じ感覚を繰り返したいんです
再現したいんです だからバカだから同じものに引っかかるんです
例えば この男と女の間で生まれる愛着もそうなんですよ
男は初めての女性を触ってみたら
えらい気分がよくなっちゃうんです
この感覚はもう忘れて忘れてはいけませんと
そうっと欲しいやと言って
その人に恋して愛着してしまっちゃうんです
実はどんな女触ったっても同じやと
うなぎ触ってるような感じやと理解すれば
そんなに愛着は生まれませんよ
目隠しをしてね 女性の手を触っても
うなぎを触っても同じだと思いますけど
まあうなぎはちょっと冷たいだけで
で あの だから男はね 不倫したりもするでしょう
結婚したら なんでお前不倫やっていう場合は
男 別に不倫してるわけじゃないんです
その人と結婚した時は愛着が
執着が生まれたんですね
この感覚をという感覚は
でも女性というのは毎日誰でも毎日変化するでしょ
体は それが毎日触れているんだから
いつでも なんかあの初めの感覚はもうないんです
あのびっくりした感覚は
だからそこら辺の皆さんで
突然若い女の人が座ってね
なんか体にぶつけたら
あの感覚と似てるんだということでね
あのかつてのね 初恋の時の感覚に似てるんですよ
これでやっちゃいますよ
不倫は だから女性は理解しないでしょう
男は不倫したって でも私はお前のこと好きやと
怒るでしょ？言われたら本当ですよ
言ってることは だってなんであんた不倫するのかと
それそんなこと言ったっても
お前のこと好きやと だからこの心理学から見れば言ってること本当なんです
あの初恋の時の感覚が欲しいんですよ
それ変わってないんです
執着ですから それ言ってるんです
だから頭おかしいでしょ
はっきり言えば だからこの仏教心理学を学べば
そういうことはいとも簡単に解決できますよ
例えば まあ気持ちいい感覚だったら気持ちいいでいいんです
でも明後日は別な感覚でしょうと
この女はあと 矛盾 だからと理解しておけば
例えば お風呂に入る前の女性を抱いてみる
お風呂に入って上がってから抱いて同じじゃないでしょ
ですから その都度その都度感覚が変わりますよと
ですから その都度その都度の渇愛も変わりますよと思っちゃえばOKなのに
このややこしい執着祭がね
割り込んで全部おかしくするんです
どうしますか？一旦休憩にします
では そろそろ始まります
あの 今まで説明したのは
このお釈迦様のある経典のあの大体四行です
今までの内容は全部四行で終わっていたんです
四行もかかってなかったっけ
パーリ語ではね タッタカタマンビッカラウパーダーナ
チャッターローマニビッカラウパーダーナニ
カームーパーダーナ ディットーウパーダーナ
えっと 何でしたっけ？まあ
そういうやつですね 忘れちゃった
シーラッパットパラマースーパーダーナとアットワードパーダーナですね
はい それで次の経典に入ります
この経典は大体七 八ページになるんです
から 全部終わりまでやります
それでも このお釈迦様の最期
信者さんがいて アナートピンディカコジというんですね
日本語ではギッコドクコジという風な
日本語の仏教の世界では知られている人で
で お釈迦様にはあのとお坊さんたちにもたくさんお布施をした方なんですね
この祇園精舎を作って
あの仏法僧に寄付した人で
これでお釈迦様にとってはこの完全完備整理した
いるところをいただいたんですね
お釈迦様はそこで提携したわけじゃないんだけど
そこで一応拠点が現れたんですね
仏教に でなきゃ お釈迦様ずっとホームレスで
比丘たちもね これでこのアナンドピンディカさんのおかげで
拠点がちょっといいところで
いいでっかい公園を買っちゃってね
今もあります まあ今あの史跡しかないんですけど
ですから やっぱり最期信者さんの中で
この人はやったことは第一なんですね
そこまですごいことは誰にもできなかった
王様たちにもできなかったんです
で 第一位と認められたんです
最後に重病で  これどうやって読むんですかね
漢字を集めただけですけど
臨終のところに  臨終の床に
あの 横になったんですね
これ読めないんだから
もういろんな方法で漢字集めてつなげたんです
けど あの まあ倒れちゃったんですね
最後に そこで彼が 大体仏教の修行する人々はね
病気になったらわかります
これは終わりだと これが最後だと
この病気ならもう治りますよとか
それを知ってます なんとかなりそうと
その心の働き よくわかってますね
もう業が消えていくと
もうもう残りないんだよと
アナートピンディカさんが倒れたところで
もう終わるとわかったんですね
だからもう亡くなるんだからさようならと言わないんですね
仏教はそういうことない
死ぬことは まあじゃあバイバイという感じで
バイバイと言えないんですね
一応 別れのご挨拶をして終わりにするんです
自分はもう動かないでしょ
ですから 家来の人々に
あんたは祇園精舎に行って
お釈迦様にアナートピンディカコジがお釈迦様の礼をしますと
今アナートピンディカコジがお寺に来られない
かなり重病で倒れて見込めない状態でいる
ですから お釈迦様に最後の礼をしますと
やってくださいと それからサーリプッタ尊者がいるところにも
アーナンダ尊者がいるところにも行ってくださいと
言って この二人にも今
アナターピンの口が重病で倒れて寝たきり状態でいますよと
ですから深く礼拝しますと
もし両尊者がお見舞いに来ていただければ
とてもありがたいと お釈迦様には言わなかったんです
そこはメッセージを受けたら
この 2人のお坊様がサーリプッタ老僧侶がアナタの病気の家に行くんです
お見舞いに行って様子を聞くんです
どうですか？何か見込みありますか？といったら
えっ？全く見込みがないんだと
どんどん苦しみが悪化していく一方ですと
見込みの気配は全くないんだと
あ そうですかと ということで
もう終わりやと みんなもう覚悟するんです
治る見込みがないことをわかって
最後の説法をするんです
時々私にも質問されたことあります
人が亡くなって亡くなって亡くなる時前にね
まあ何か言葉をかけたいんだけど
どんな言葉かければいいかと
これがその参考の経典ですけど
できることなら頑張ってください
これは仏教の世界で死ぬ時教える経典なんです
サーリプッタ尊者の説法
執着を捨てましょう それがテーマです
だから あの経験もう一度とは死ねないでしょう
もう十分や もういいやという気持ちにならなくちゃいけないんです
もうさようなら もう結構やと
だからもう結構ですという気持ちになってほしいんです
もうこりごりですと それが執着していることなんです
これはマッジムニ会の 143番目だと思いますけど
なんか推測で数えたんです
6つの感覚器官に執着を捨てる
タスマーティへがはぺティタスマーティハテーがはぺティエーワンシッキタッバンコジオ
それならこのように戒めなさい
こういうエピソードなんですね
尊者 私はまあこれで終わりですね
亡く死ぬ もうもう治らないんです
この病はこのままやと思いますよと
ああ それではこういう風に戒めなさいって順番でいくんです
ああ 大変だ そんなこと言わないでくれとかね
頑張ってよとかね それはないんです
仏教では 気を落とさないでくださいとかね
時々落とせという時もあります
諦めろよと この場合は諦めよ
捨てなさいよと言っているんです
ナチャックンウパーディーサーマナチメチャックニッシタンヴィニャータンヴィニャーナンバヴィセティ
目に執着しません 私の意識が目に依拠しないように目に執着しない
ないの あの目に何て言ったっけ？認識が影響しないように
目に認識が影響するっていうことは
目に執着しているんですね
意識ですね 目に意識が引っかからないように
それで次もいきます 眼耳鼻舌体に執着しません
私の意識が眼耳鼻舌体に影響しないように
これ皆様もちょっとこれ瞑想でしょ？だからちょっと瞑想みたいな感じで
ちょっと自己観察でちょっと考えて感じたら意味がわかるかも
目耳鼻に引っかからない
六根にも心にも引っかからないと
さようならと バイバイと
という気持ち ちょっと作ってみてください
はい 次のチャプター 六つの対象
六つの認識 色声香味触法に執着しない
私の認識は色声香味触法に影響しないように戒めると
それで自分の体の六根だけじゃなくて
外から情報入るでしょ
そういうものにもはい
さようなら もう関わりは持たないと
見えるものいっぱいあるでしょ
まあそれはそれで結構ですと
聞こえる音 音があるでしょ
はい まあそれはそれで結構ですと
で 六個対象にも執着を捨てる
眼識 耳識 鼻識 舌識 身識
意識に意識の執着を捨てる
次に目にデータ触れたら
まあさようならと言ってもね
見えるものにはさようなら
目にもさようならと言っても見えてるんだからね
見えてるということは眼識が起きてるんですね
あ この見える眼識にも執着しないと
えーと 耳識にも執着しないと
六識にも執着しないことにする
自分の意識は六識に影響しないように
いる場所がなくなっちゃうでしょ
心には 私の認識は眼識
鼻識 眼識 耳識 読み方ちょっとわかりませんだけど
色識 身識 意識に影響しないようにと戒める
次のチャプター 触と感覚
パッサとヴェーダナ 眼耳鼻舌体に起こる触に執着しないのだ
これもちょっと感じてください
今 体にいろんなもの触れてるでしょ
体に空気が触れてるし
座ってる椅子の椅子が触れてるしね
私の音が耳に触れてるし
それで目を開けてるんだから
いろんな触れてるでしょ
この体にデータ触れる
このそれちょっと感じてみてください
触れてるんだと 触という働きなんですね
あれ どうったことないんだけど
それでどうたこと起きるんですよ
この触れることですべて成り立っちゃうんです
ただの触れることだから
まあいいやと そんなことに執着しないよと
それに私の意識が引っかからないようにしましょうと
私の意識は眼耳鼻舌体の触に影響しないように
触とは六の感覚器官で情報を受け取ることですね
それは私の注釈ですね
あの触ってわからないんだったら
この情報を受け取るんですね
だから耳にデータが入ると
耳目にデータが入ると目が受け取るんです
受理するんです 耳に音が入ると耳が自動的に受けるんですよ
拒否しないんですよ 受けるんです
だから必ず触が生まれるんです
眼耳鼻舌体に起こる感覚に執着しないように
次のことを皆様も感じてみた方がいいんですね
で 見えると何か感じる
聞こえると何か感じる
座っていると感じる 触よりは感じることわかりやすいんですよ
触はだいたい感じません
一般的には ちょっと論理的になんですね
しかし 具体的に感じますね
今座っていらっしゃるんだから
結構お尻やら背中やらね
よく感じているでしょう
だからそれが感覚 組織です
ただ感じるんじゃない
お尻とまたいっぱい組織が働いて
この感覚を引き起こしているんです
はい この感覚には執着しない
放っておきますと 私はこの執着しないということは
瞑想を教えるとき使う言葉は放っておきましょうというキーワードなんです
悟りのキーワードなんです
だからウパーダナしないようにと言ったって誰もわかってくれません
だから私はこの経典は全部一言葉に集約しています
放っておけ だから瞑想する方々にはものすごく厳しく言うんだけど
瞑想するときは何があっても放っておきなさいよと
それだけはみんなやってくれないんですよ
それで瞑想しているんだけど
何の成長もないんだと文句を言うんですね
もう蹴るしかないんですね
その場合は それでこの体の中で六つの感覚組織が生まれては生まれては流れるわ
流れるわ流れるわ ただ
私 喋っている間 ずっと耳の中で感覚が生まれて消えて生まれて消えて流れていくんですね
この六つの流れに執着しない
放っておきます 私の意識がその感覚組織に影響しないようにと
私の意識はゲンニービーセッション
胃に起こる感覚に影響しないようにと戒めなさいよと言うんですね
これで一つのチャプターが終わり
それから外界と内界ということ
うーん これ相当難しい
だから止まってるんです
まあ外界内界とわかりますね
病院じゃないんです 外科と内科じゃないんで
この内界っていうのは
自分自身が 外界っていうのは自分以外すべて外界
この外界内界は構成しているのはパトリーダート
地界 アーポーダート 水界
テジョーダート 火界 ワーヨダート
風界 アーカースダート
空海 ヴィンヤーナダート
色界なんですね 皆様方はもしかすると地水火風という物質の四つ知っていると思いますね
仏教はすべての宇宙の物質は四種類にしているんです
地水火風 地水火風で全ての物質世界が現れると
目に見えない あのブラックダークマターも地水火風なんです
ただ形が違っちゃって
我々にはもう認識できません
で 地水火風で物が現れると
当然空間も成り立つんですね
だから私たち一般人が空間があって
その中に何かを作ると思ってるでしょ
こちら空き地があります
ここで家を作りましょうと
だからまず空間があって
そちらにも何か作るという
本当はそうかなと これどちらでもないんです
で 我々は空き地と空間と思うのは
ものがあって そこから引き算して
こちらは空間やと思うんですね
だから人間があれは頭で言うだけで
本当はまずものがあって
ものがないところに空間というんです
で 推測で空間認識できるんです
それであの とにかく地水火風があって
ものがあると空間も現れます
しかし アビダンマでは空間は界として教えません
地水火風と また他の物質で終わっちゃうんです
空は使いません で 空も物質だよと言ったのは
このえっとえっとえっとえっと
ボスバンズさんですね
まあそれは専門家の世界でやめます
いわゆる有識論じゃなくて
精神世界でね で これはまあテーラワーダ仏教は間違いないと
それからヴィンヤーナダート
ヴィンヤーナっていうのは心ですね
今 宇宙で考えるんだだから
宇宙のすべての物質を分解してみると
地水火風と空間と色 と言って
どれぐらいになります？ 6ですね
即になるんです 私の認識は
地界 水界 火界 風界 空界
色界に依拠しないように
土に執着してどうする？空気に執着してどうする？だからこちらにある空気と風と
この中にあるか同じものでしょ
外にある土と体ができている土
同じものでしょ なんで執着するんですかね
じゃあ空間に体の中 空間があるでしょ
ありがたいこと この空間はと
ただの空間でしょうね
そっちの空間とこっちの空間と
例えば鼻の穴に空間がありますね
こうやってここら辺の空間と何が違いますかね
すごい そんな捨ててほっとけ
こんなのは 執着しないように
で それから心にも執着しないようにと
この六つは自分と外を構成する元素なのです
元素という言葉が適切かどうかよくよくわからないんだから
ハテナを入れておいたんです
仏教では界という言葉を使うんですね
まあ大雑把で言えば元素というふうな意味なんですね
しかし あの 学校でいう元素と
まあちょっと違うかもしれませんね
たくさんありすぎですね
元素は 元だったらもっとシンプルであるはずなんですね
いくつかでしかできてないはずなんですね
それでダートっていうのは
英語で言えばエレメンツなんですね
それであえて界っていう言葉を使って
いろんなあれで これでいろんな方法で教えるんですよ
執着してますよと これ今項目 3つぐらい飛ばし飛ばさなくて言ったんだけど
一つの項目でも全て入ってるんです
これ見ても一切入ってるでしょ
宇宙も自分も求めて  6つのエレメントにして
それエレメントには執着しないよと
全部入ってます 次 体を構成している五蘊
また別なやり方から説法するんです
これ 長い説法はぎゅーっと縮めて縮めてやります
ルーパカンダ 色蘊 ヴェーダナカンダ
受蘊 サンニャカンダ 想蘊
サンカーラカンダ 行蘊
ヴィンヤーナカンダ 識蘊に執着しないのだ
この体は色受想行識という四つのものでできているんです
その場合は界 ダート エレメントは言わないんです
複雑ですからね 色とは物質のこと
地水火風のこと まず体に物質があります
次 受蘊があります 受蘊というのは感じること
この物体が感じるんですね
感じる組織があります
あの 想蘊っていうのは
感じてから概念作るんで考えるんですね
青いやら赤いやら花やらご飯とかおにぎりとかね
いろいろ感じるでしょ？思うでしょ？その思うこと
いわゆる概念作ることは想蘊
これ巨大な組織ですよ
何か見えては頭の中で想が生まれる
何か聞いたら頭の中で想が生まれる
だからもうハッチャンめちゃ想が生まれっぱなしなんです
それというのは概念 それから行蘊
行蘊っていうのは この肉体に感覚が現れると
何かしたい 何かしたい
何かしたいと いつでも衝動があるんですよ
このままボケーってることできないんです
例えば音を聞いた途端
それから何かしたいという気持ちが生まれているんです
何でもいいんだから何かしたいというふうに出てくるんです
例えばご飯食べたとする
すぐお茶飲みたいとなっているんです
ご飯食べて終わった瞬間
食べて終わったという想が生まれたら
次 じゃあ片付きますとも
次の衝動が生まれているんです
だから衝動が生まれない瞬間ないんです
それは行蘊というんです
それから認識しなきゃ何もできんでしょ
認識しているんですね
いつだって それは識蘊というんです
その 5つの組織で体ができているんです
この組織に仏教では蘊という漢字を
塊という意味なんですね
組み立てているものってスカンダというんです
この場合 スカンダ組織に仏教を使う言葉はカーヤなんですね
時々五蘊ではなくて カーヤも使う場合があります
蘊の運を漢字を付けちゃって
カーヤ これは漢訳にするとおかしくなっちゃいます
パーリ語ではおかしくなりません
ルーパカーヤ ウェーダナーカーヤ
サンニャーカーヤ サンカーラカーヤ
ヴィンヤーナカーヤとも言います
だから組織なんです これには執着しないでくれと
見てくださいと 分析している肉体
あなた執着する あなたの感覚に執着する
する必要ないでしょうやと
あなたのごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ頭の中で考えている
この概念 あれや好きや
執着する 執着認識に執着しないと
私は色蘊 受蘊 想蘊 行蘊
色蘊に依拠 私 私は間違って私の認識はなんです
依拠しないようにと 生命とのとはこの 5つの働きで組織でできているんです
それじゃあ それ以外何もありません
生命といえば至って簡単
5種類の組織の集まりなんです
こうなんです ここはないんです
魂 霊魂ないんです お釈迦様は挑戦するんです
あるならば言ってくれよと
ただだけです 次 別なチャプターで別な項目で説法を続くんです
生命の次元は 9つあります
この 9つの次元 まず覚えておきましょう
欲界という次元があります
欲界 欲界っていうのは
目 耳 鼻などを使う世界
それで生命としては地獄の生命
畜生の生命 餓鬼道の生命
それから人間 それから神々
天界 みんな同じ次元なんです
目 耳 鼻を使って生きているんです
目 耳 鼻などなかったら生きていられないんです
肉体がなかった 肉体がなくて
物体的な体がなければ生きていられないんです
欲界というんです だから一つの次元です
皆様は神々のこと知らんと言ったっても同じ次元だからね
で 洗濯でもすればわかると思います
次はこの色界の四つの次元があります
色界っていうのは このまた体を持っている生命なんですけど
梵天 神ではないんです
瞑想してサマーディを作って
もう神を飛ばしちゃって上の次元に行ってるんです
神の境地をはるかに飛ばしてるんです
ですから梵天と言うんです
梵天 優れた境地 これで梵天になっても
それなりの何か体があるんです
体があるのは この命をつなげるための体であって
別に見たい 聞きたい 味わいたいはないんです
だからこのその機能はない
いらない もう進化しているんです
我々は見なきゃ死んじゃいます
聞こえなかったら死んじゃいます
この六根機能しないと死んじゃいます
梵天には体があるんだけど
見なきゃ死ぬってことはないんです
だからこのその器官は働かないんです
意識だけで働くのは 見えるんだそうで見えると聞こえるだけはできるそうです
見る機能 聞く機能はあるんだけど
あんまり使う必要はないんです
ずっと清浄状態でいるんです
それでつですね その梵天は
そうするとつですね それから無色界は次元つ
無色界っていうのは この体はいらない生命
心だけで十分です 心ってものじゃないんです
だからこれは誰にもコンタクトできないんです
ものじゃないんだから
四次元があるんです それも梵天の一種ですね
それで九つです 生命はどこに生まれ変わったっても
そこの九つの中でうろうろうろうろ回らなくちゃあかんです
大体欲界で回ってますよ
地獄に落ちるは 人間になるは
動物になるは もうもう様々
天国にも行くわとかね
瞑想修行すると天国を飛ばして梵天に行けます
それだけ いくらなんでもその九つの中で回転しているんです
生命の次元が そこでサーリプッタ尊者がこの九つのも執着しないように戒めなさいと
言うべきところ言ってないんです
言ってるのは無色界の四つしか説かれてないんです
この理由は まあ聞かないでください
私もわかりません 推測はできますけど
今日は注釈書は調べてないんです
ですから注釈書の意味もちょっと言えないんですけど
あの 例えばね アーナンダピンディカさんがお釈迦様に毎日のように会っていた人だからね
あんたね 地獄に落ちるなよと言ったってバカバカらしい話でしょ
この人間の世界に執着するなというっとさんざん聞いてるんだからね
だからおそらくそういう欲がないでしょうと推測したかも
それから 色界の梵天についても何も言ってないんですね
無色界に言うんですね
おそらくアーナンダピンディカ王子がおそらくではない
これは確かなんですけど
禅定はないんですよ 悟っていたんですよ
預流果に 悟っていたんだけど
瞑想する暇がないんだからね
お坊さんたちの面倒を見ることで朝から晩まで忙しいんです
もう富豪家でしたけど
まあ商売もついでにやったんですけど
お釈迦様の世話をすることは仕事なんです
本人の だから瞑想する暇はなかったんですけど
預流果に悟ってるんですね
だからこれだけ確かです
無色界は何者かとさっぱりわからない
これは皆様にも説法しても理解できないんです
無色界っていうのは物質性のない世界なんです
だから物質性のないと言えば
世界という言葉は使えないんです
物質のない次元といったら次元も使えないんです
だからこれがこの色界の瞑想を終わった修行者にのみ経験できる境地なんです
だから アーナンダプリンでコジが無色界のことはさっぱりわからなかったと思います
わからない世界にはやっぱり未練が起きますよ
あちらも行ってみたいなとか
一度も行ったことないんだよとかね
出てきます だからそこはあえて取り上げて
私は空無辺処色 これはあの四つの次元の名前なんです
難しいでしょ 構いません
わからないでしょ それでも構わない
わからないんです 一般の方々は
空無辺処色無辺処無処有処
非想非非想 なんとかなんとか
そうにもあらす 非想にもあらすという境地ですね
執着しないのだと戒めてくださいと
もし万が一 アーナンダプリンでコジが無色界は経験したことはないし
あれなんの世界ですかね
一番高い世界というんだから
一度味わってみたいなとか思っちゃったらまずいんですね
これを一番高いトップの次元なんですね
捨てなさい そんなのは捨てろよと
で 意味 ちょっと説明します
空無辺っていうのは空間のこと
あの空間は我々一般人
人間には認識できません
推測で知ってるつもりなんです
目に空間は映りません
目にはものは映るんです
耳に音は映るんだけど
音がない状態は映りません
だから空間の認識できないんです
それで初めて空間は無辺であると認識するんです
これ どんな認識かとさっぱりなんですよ
当然空間は無辺なんです
リミットがないんです
それを認識するんです
それが無色界の第1の次元
それからここまで知識が空間が認識したっていうことは
心が無限に広がれる力だと
いて色無辺ということを経験するんです
これは2番目で それで次
色と言ったっても瞬間で消えるものでしょ
何もないと ない 無 無を認識するんです
皆様方が認識する無というのは
あれあるなんですよ 漢字でしょ
なんとか何か変な尺みたいな漢字がありますね
こちらもありますね これはウですよ
無に漢字があること自体
どういうことですかね
もう無にしちゃって理解するんです
これ違うでしょ 話は それでこの3番目
この無を何もないことを認識するんです
認識に成功したら 第3番目の洗浄で第3番目の次元なんです
次に何も認識しない時は心はどうなっていますかね？無を認識すると
例えばバラの花を認識すると心はどうなっています？それはわかりますよね
気持ちいいとかなんとか起きてるでしょ
音楽を認識すると心はどうなるんですかね
音楽に合わせて心も踊っているでしょ
では 無を認識するとき
なんかわからないね 何も波を立たないんですよ
波を起こさないんです
しかし 波を起こさないと心じゃないんです
だからそう 概念があるとも言えないし
ないとも言えないし状態になるんです
それは 4番目 非想 そうはないんです
では 非想ですか？いい
非想でもないんだ だから非非想
非想でありながら非非想でもあるという境地
お釈迦様は苦労したんで
言葉を入れるために そういうネオサンニャーナーサンニャーテナというところがあるんだということで
この 4つの次元なんですね
なんか話を聞くと 絶対人間に無理な境地だからやってみたいなって気分が生まれるかも
じゃあ頑張って空を認識してやると
やっちゃえばできますよ
やっちゃえばできます
まず普通の瞑想するんです
普通の瞑想して戦場を作るんです
戦場を作ってからこれに挑戦するんです
あの戦場がなければできません
ただ そのままではできません
まず瞑想を作って サマーディを作って
サマーディは 4つあります
この 4つにも行かなくちゃいけない
4番目のサマーディに行くと
だいたい体の機能はほとんど止まっているんです
それから言葉の機能は完全停止しているんです
それで言葉なし そうで概念
そう 概念 言葉ない状態で次の瞑想が始まるんです
だからこれしないと そうすると難しいんです
私の認識は空無辺処云々で
非非想非非想処に依拠しないようにと戒めなさい
この世 あの世 此岸彼岸
執着する 捨てちゃいます
向こうの何でしたか お盆とかやるもんじゃないんです
捨てるんです そんなの
ね イドローカンウパーディッサーミ
この世に執着しないのだ
ね パラローカンウパーディッサーミ
あの世にも執着しないのだ
私の認識は この世にもあの世にも依拠しないように
どうですか？それは仏教はよく
あの こちら花見入れたのは経典のポイントを割ったという意味もありますながら
あるながら 皆様ならなんとかこれぐらいわかると思いますよ
今までの説法はわからなくても
この世といえばなんとなくわかるでしょ
この世は捨てるんです
この世を捨てる あの世を期待するでしょ
あの世も捨てるんです
成仏は捨てるんです すべて放っておくんです
死ぬ時はそれなんです
やるべきことは 皆様にできますか？皆様の誰か最期を迎えている時はね
では すべて放っておきなさいよとかね
執着を捨てましょうよと教えることはね
難しいでしょ だから言い方にも私も時々言い方あります
あんたそれ持っていく？おじいさん
何か持っていくものある？何もないだろうね
それでいいやと だから持っていくものは何もない
持っていく では行く必要もないんです
どこかに行く あの世に行く
それもないんです あの世に行きますって言ったら
それ執着でしょ で これはちょっとまた難しくなるんです
花入れたところはだいたい皆様に理解できるところで
ヤンビメディッタンスタンムったムタン
ヴィンヤータンパッタン
パリエシタンアヌパリエシタンアヌイチャリタンマナサタンピノウパーディッシャーミ
見たり聞いたり 感じたり
認識したり また思考や考察によって得た一切の概念に執着しないのだ
すべて捨てましょう いっぱい勉強したり
見たり 聞いたり 考えたり
経験したりして いろんなものが脳細胞に溜まってるでしょ
すべて捨てるんです 捨てるんじゃなくて執着しないんです
私の認識は思考や概念に影響しないようにと
はい これでサーリプッタ尊者の経典が終わったんです
この思考 思考に執着しないでくれと
概念に知識に執着 執着
執着しないでくれってことも
大体仏教のすごい大胆な言葉なんですね
世の中 我々は知識はすごい執着しますよ
学んだものはね いるんですよ
この特にお坊さんたちの中でも
自分の名前に尾っぽが長い
尾っぽもうつけるんですね
何だら博士 何だら教授
何だらかんだらとかね
なんだこれ やっぱ執着
そんなものでしょ そこでお坊さん同士で自分たちでいろいろ敬語じゃなくて
そういう称号を勝手に作って作って与えるんですね
長老たちが 何時にはこの称号を与えて
何時はこの称号与えると
バカバカらしくて もう私にもこの最高のもう与えられる称号をね
与えますからとかね もう決めてるんだから
ちゃんと願書を出してくれとか
1年前ぐらいにでもやりましてね
このお寺にも去年ね 看守様が来てね
もう明確にみんなの前で言うんですね
まあこれは私たちは決めてますからとかね
でも私は行かないんです
本山に行って願書を出しません
何のためかと 皆さんもおそらく知らないくらいと
私の名前は正式名を書くとね
結構もう 2 メートルぐらいになると思いますよ
バカバカらしくて 何やこれと
それで勝手に宗派で本山でいろいろ称号を作って
それは適切な人を選んで与えたり
あるいはまあまあ政治的なカーストですからね
あいつを抑えておいた方がいいやとか
あの坊主をあの坊主をちょっと称えてあげた方がいいやとか
そんなもんでしょう で
ですから この皆様にはそういう問題がないんだけど
日本の方々も勲章をもらったら結構喜ぶと思いますよ
あの学校で博士とか取るのは構わないんだけど
一番無意味 バカバカらしいのは勲章でしょ
何の用ないんですね あれは
だからあと 3ヶ月間で死ぬんだそうとかね
この政府がね 計算するんですよ
立派な長老たちのことをね
あの先生はね あと 1年持たないでしょうね
では今度勲章に決めましょうよとかね
これ 天皇陛下にしたってえらい迷惑でしょうし
この大事な日本の国に立派に貢献した人々を侮辱しているんですよ
これは私の主観ですけどね
勲章をもらっている方々は本当にみんな立派な方々で
それは問題ないんです
であの勲章は何だと 日本人だからこれいらんと言えないでしょう
勲章は天皇陛下出すんだから
手ではあげないんだけど
一応天皇陛下が待っていて
総理大臣というね わけのわからない人がもらっちゃいますけどね
天皇陛下 じゃあこれもらってきてというならばね
どうでしょう ちょっと執着が
ありがたいなとかね あれも執着ですよ
ある日 あの昔 大使館に運転した人はちょっと年寄りの方で
あの昭和天皇の時なんですね
まあよくね 大使たちが行ったり来たりするでしょ
だから大使の家ではね
昭和天皇を書いたものやらもらったものと
まあダラダラあったし
そこであるある格好は色紙あって
これあれ これは昭和天皇エンペラーが書いてもらうというんで
全然全くごく普通でね
あ そうですか 私はそこで日本人ならこれ腰が抜けるでしょうなとか思ったんですね
もうちゃんと書いてくれたものでね
ただどこかで入れてるだけで
そこで 私はこうすると
この国ではとね あんた方そんな風にもう一般的に何とかと扱っていた
言ったら まあそうですね
でいて このある正月であの天皇陛下からね
なんか鯛でしたっけね
丸ごとにもう焼いたものをね
で それでちゃんと花菊でしたっけ？の花あるあって
そんなそのまますごいかっこよくて
お土産でもらうんですね
でもそのままの姿の魚は我々西洋人食いません
これぶつ切りにしてもらわないと形を壊してもらわないと
そこであの これは日本の食だから
大使がこの運転手に君
これもらったらどうですかと
これ 皇居からもらったその箱で
その包装で そのハンコで
一般の人もらってどうするんですかね
この人がものすごく涙流したりして
家に持っていって これはなんかお供えして拝んでいたみたいです
食ったかどうかわかりません
食った方がよかったんですけど
だからやっぱり日本の一般の方々はね
天皇陛下に対してはすごい気持ち持ってますし
だから勲章いらんという一言は言えないでしょ
それでだからといって長老たちを侮辱していいのかと
だからもう若い時あげようと言いたい
ただそれだけの話なんです
人々は何かいいことをしたら
毎年ね もうさっさとあげちゃえばみんな頑張るでしょ
勲章 2つもらうぞと頑張るでしょ
それで国が発展しますからね
何か科学を発展した 発見した人にね
年はまあ 50歳ですけど
あげちゃう これでただじすみません
この人はまたがむしゃら研究するんです
それでもう一つ何か発見発表するんです
あ そうか じゃあもう一つあげましょうと
そんな感じでやっちゃえばいいのにね
そんな金もかからないしね
どこかに工場作れますし
はい まあそれでこのこの最後の項目でそれ言ってますよ
知識に 学問に 見たものに
聞いたものに 自分自身で考えて達した結論などに
哲学などに一切執着するな
捨てろよと 放っておけよと
死ぬ瞬間イメージしてみてください
皆さんが ご自分が今あと 4 分で 1 分で死ぬんだと
捨てられますでしょ それだったら
でもあと 1 分では死にますけど
私の博士の称号はこれだけは
あのね 困った この勲章はと
意味がないでしょ だから捨てた方がいいんです
この捨てるということは
ポイ捨てって意味じゃなくて
気持ちでさようならと
関係ないんだと 放っておきますと
気にしないという気持ちなんです
はい それで説法を聞いて
アナータピンディカコジがまた蘇ったと言ったら
皆様ありがたがりますからね
それは宗教の話で この話を聞いたら
摩訶不思議な奇跡が起きて
アナータピンディカさんがまた若返ってあと 100 年生きてまったと
コジは説法終わりで説法の終わりで泣き崩れたんです
泣いちゃったんです あなたは落ち込んだのかと
アーナンダ尊者が尋ねる
すごい泣くんですよ ああ
あんた落ち込んだんですねって
アーナンダ尊者でコジ答えます
違います 長い間 私は釈尊と比丘サンガと親密に付き合ってきたんです
すごい長い間 しかし このような感動的
おそらくショックでしょうね
感動的な教えを聞いたことはありません
今日初めて聞いたんだと
こんな教えあるのに もう 20年以上ブッダと付き合っていたんですよ
一度も聞いてないんです
もう怒れない もう死にますからね
だから泣いちゃったんです
教えてくれなかったと
サーリプッタ尊者が答えるんです
コジよ これは在家にふさわしくない
ふさわしい理解できる教えではありません
出家にのみ適用する教えだと
だから出家には別に日常茶飯事の教典です
いわば内容はね この教典ではなくて
在家には教えませんね
説法するときでも できるだけそこはもう避けて避けて避けて
六波羅蜜経とか 良い夫婦関係はなんせやとか
そんなものを教えるんです
良い友達とは何ですか？とかね
どうすればいい友達作れるの？そんなことを教えて終わっちゃいます
これは教えません これはもう管轄外でも頭で理解できないんですね
コジ答えます ではお願いします
在家にもこのような威力のある法をこれから教えてあげてください
理解できる人もいるのですと
みんなダメなわけないでしょうにと
いるんだよと 理解できる人はと
両尊者が出かけて間もなくコジが亡くなります
兜率天に生まれるのです
残念でしたね 奇跡的に奇跡が起きて蘇ってこなかったんです
ごく普通に死んじゃったんです
しかし 死んだ瞬間で兜率天なんです
それでその兜率天になったら名前違います
名前はジャナ・ワサバなんです
だから目蓋閉じる間で名前まで変わりますからね
アナータピンディカっていうのは名前じゃなくあだ名なんです
名前はスダッタなんです
誰も知らない それは だから経典を見るとアナータピンディカサーラーメとパーリ語で出るんですね
だから彼の名前がかなり PR されてますよ
もう 4分の3ぐらいの経典にアナータピンディカサーラーメと出てきますからね
だからコジの名前を残してますが
本名はないんですね 本名はスダッタ
天界に生まれた瞬間に名前はジャナ・ワサバなんです
そこでその神がすっとお釈迦様のところに来たんです
またサーリプッタ尊者がまた歩いてくるでしょうね
遠い距離を歩いて その間にもう死んでるんです
こっちが死んで天界に生まれて
またお釈迦様と喋ってるんです
で 釈尊がここに登場しますね
アーナンダビンデカ天が釈尊の前に現れて礼をして歓喜の偈を歌うんです
あの偈は書いてない ちょっとあの枚数が高くなりますからね
意味だけ 一 法王と仙人たちが住むこの祇園精舎は
私に喜びを与えるという偈なんです
法王っていうのはお釈迦様のこと
善行為 智慧 法 道徳的な生き方でのみ
人の心は清らかになる
心清らかになりたければ
道徳と善行為と智慧と法と道徳だよと
3番目の歌は 自分の幸福を望む理性のある人は
智慧で真理を理解するのですと
ちょっと頭で苦しいかもしれませんだけど
ブッダの教えを理解しろよと
それだったら自分の幸福になりますよ
と  4番目の歌 完全たる戒を守って智慧を智慧が備わっているサーリプッタ尊者は
解脱に達している比丘たちの中ででも最勝の方である
サーリプッタ尊者には誰も叶いませんよと
解脱に達している方々の中でも輝いてますよ
サーリプッタ尊者が 次の朝
お釈迦様はこの旨を比丘たちに告げられます
次の朝 比丘たち  あのね
そんなアナタ便りこと言わなかったんですね
夜 神様を一人来てね こんな歌を歌って帰っちゃったよと
これこういう歌よと 何のことなく告げたんです
歌四つですね アナンジャ尊者反応するんですね
尊師 その神はアーナンダビンデカ居士だと思いますと
だって彼は誰よりもサーリプッタ尊者を尊敬していたんだから
アーナンダコジはね お坊さんたちにすごく親切でお世話していたんだけども
サーリプッタ尊者のことはむっちゃ尊敬していましたよと
だからその偈はね その神という人がね
おそらくアーナンダビンデカだと
そしたらお釈迦様は まああなたの推測は当たっていますと
あなたよく推測しましたと
ということで 経典が終わります
そこで四行の経典にはね
二時間以上かかりましたけど
八ページよりも続くの経典がそれ終了したんです
もうとにかく省略って何も項目捨ててないんですけどね
これ長い経典 これは煩悩
煩悩じゃなくて 執着を捨てなさいと言えば
何に際する執着かといえば
それ一切なんです 塵一つにも執着しないよと
天国にも誰にも で そういうことで経典が終わるんですね
これは私の意識はという言葉を私はあえて使ったんですね
だからいつでも自分の意識が働いている
意識が執着で働くんですね
何かに執着して 次の意識じゃない
次の意識 だから意識が次に次にどうしようかなと言えば執着させてないんですね
それがこの涅槃を生みするんですよ
意識には行くところがなくなっちゃうんです
心には心こそ宇宙のパワーより心にパワーがあるんですよ
あるのに行くところはなくなる
なくなる それでどうなるのかということは涅槃ということなんです
だからそれについて語るなよと
もうわからない人間には
涅槃のギリギリのところまで説明できます
それでサーリプッタ尊者が涅槃を語ったんですね
最後に後がきもありますね
サーリプッタ尊者は居士を死ぬ前に阿羅漢果に昇格させようと思ったでしょうと思いますね
これはもう出家に教える教えでね
出家の中でももう死にかけていると
さっと阿羅漢になって悟って死んでほしいんですね
解脱に達して だからいうことで
わざわざアナタ個人にそれを教えたんです
だから本当はすごい特別扱いなんでしょ
これは一生修行していくつかの悟りの段階に達していっているお坊さんたちも
まあ年寄りが出家したりするとね
また特に健康な食べ物もないし
結構亡くなりますよ 病気で
その時はお坊さんたちがさっさと行って
とにかく死ぬ前に完全解脱に達して死なせてあげなくちゃということで頑張るんです
だからこれ特別経典なんですよ
内容は 出家に教えてあげた
それがアナパニサティに何の躊躇もなく
ダラダラダラダラとサーリプッタ尊者が教えてあげたんです
だからサーリプッタ尊者が頑張ったんです
もう阿羅漢にさせてやるぞと
しかし ここまではそこまでは成功しなかったんですね
阿羅漢になれなかったんです
とすせんに とそすせんに生まれたんですね
しかし あのよく悟ってますから
聖者ですよ 今もいるんです
自分の仏教を宣伝するんだから来ているかどうかよくわかりませんだけどね
お釈迦様も居士に なんか間違えた
居士にこの経典のように難しい説法を一度もなさらなかったんですね
お釈迦様と必ず会います
お釈迦様は何か教えてあげる
居士は全然質問しないんですよ
この居士の考えは 朝から晩までみんなお釈迦様に値折り入り
聞くは聞くは聞くは聞くは
瞬間も暇がないんだと
かわいそうに 疲れて疲れて
行っていろいろお釈迦様の布施とかね
身の回りのこととか 何かかけてそれを見て
飲み物とか持って持っていって差し上げて
礼をして黙って質問しない
それでお釈迦様が挨拶代わりに何かちょっとした教えを教えてあげる
で ありがたく聞いて帰る
難しい説法してないんです
で 注釈書はいろいろ言うんだけど
まあお釈迦様だからね
居士はこの今世では阿羅漢にはならないと知っていたと思いますね
今の生活ぶりと義務感から考えると
やっぱり執着完全にすることは無理なんですね
仏法僧に対する執着 執着は並みではなかったんだからね
これはもう並みではないんです
神々 誰もそこまでは仏法僧にはしてくれたことはないんだから
だから仏法僧に対する執着さえも捨てなくちゃあかんですよ
阿羅漢になるためには
この人にこれ言ったって無理やとということでも教えてなかったですよね
でもサーリプッタ尊者はそんなことを構わず挑戦したんです
お釈迦様はやってないんだけど
じゃあ阿羅漢にさせてみますと
でもうまくいかなかったんですね
相手の能力 相手に能力があってもなくても
これ丸じゃなくて点ですけど
究極の境地に達するまで指導するのは仏弟子たちの仕事です
だから失敗は覚悟の上で
だからまあ 仏弟子たちが真面目に真剣に
人々のことを慈しんで喋るならば
徹底的に喋った方がいいってことなんですよ
人が怒るか 気持ち悪くなって逃げるかわからない
この坊主はとかね であれはそんなことを構っちゃうと仏法は教えられなくなっちゃいますね
ですから徹底的に喋ります
喋りますけど みんな悟るかどうかはわからないんですね
これは能力次第です ですから
特に説法する側が失敗には結構慣れてます
皆さんはそれを覚えてください
皆さんは失敗に慣れてないでしょ？何でも成功すると思ってるでしょ？だからだらしないんですよ
性格が曖昧で中途半端で
失敗に慣れてみてください
すごい強くなるんです
失敗はもう当たり前で
1万回失敗すると一回ぐらいは成功するでしょう
私は日本で説法を始めたのも
この国は全く失格だと
仏教には この人間やと
理性はひとかけらも感じなかったんです
教授たちの中ででも 迷信
迷信 迷信 拝み屋 拝み屋ばっかしで
それから西洋文化のもう犬で奴隷で
自主精神はないわ 自分の物事を考えないわ
学校に行ったら羊扱いでも自由はないわ
こんなもう無理やと 仏教は
もし私が説法したら もう 1億万回失敗するのは当たり前やと
で 始めたんです 成功の覚悟の上じゃないんで
それ皆さんもうこのとんでもない性格学んでください
とんでもない性格でしょ？皆様から見れば
これはね 何も道具を持たないで
酸素も持たないで 基礎準備もしないでヒマラヤを登るようなもんでしょ
この服装で ベースキャンプで死にますからね
人生っていうのは生きるにはそういうのはそれぐらいのしぶとく生きてみなきゃダメなんです
はい これで話は終わりにしましょうね
はい 予定の時間は過ぎておりますが
何かご質問がある方いらっしゃいましたら
マイクを回しますので挙手していただいてもでしょうか
ご質問ある方 挙手をお願いします
では 真ん中の回す方  お願いします
今日の講座の中で執着の起源というところがあったと思うのですが
実は私 今週ちょっとある人に一目惚れをしまして
出張先で会った女の人だったんですけど
会いたいなって思ったんですけど
今ずっとその なんでその人と会いたくなったのかなっていうのをちょっと考えた時に
ちょうどその話を聞いたんですけど
その私がある まあその女の人を見た時に感覚が触れて
多分私が好きだって判断して
執着でもう一度会いたいと思ったんですけど
その感覚が その女の人を見た時に
声を聞いたりとか 仕草を見たりとかした時に
そのなんで好きになったのかっていうのがわからないというか
多分タイプだったと思うんですけど
そのなんでタイプなのかっていうのも
よくよく考えると なんかあんまり根拠がないような気がして
自分がなんでその人を好きだと思ったのかがよくわからなかったんですが
その対象が触れた時に好きとか嫌いとか判断をすると思うんですけど
なんでそれを判断してるのか
自分では正直ちょっとわからなかったんですが
その何を根拠に判断をしているのかというか
そのどうして好きと思うのかとか
嫌いと思うのかっていうところがちょっとわからなかったので
教えてほしいですが  うんうん
まあ時間ないだけでね
本当にすごく説明しなくちゃいけない質問だと思います
で またそうやってしっかりと具体的に質問されると
すごく役に立ちますよ
結構 これね あの人は好きになる
嫌いになるということには理由がないんですよ
それには感情というんですね
理由がないんだから また取り扱いは難しいんですね
だからやられます だからご自分がずっと考えるんですよ
なんで好きになっただろうかと
ないんです そんな理由は
ただ見た 声聞いた 触れてみた
あ 気に入った それで終わり
だからこの欲をなくすのは難しいのはそういうことなんですね
はっきりした理由が自分にわからないんですね
そちらに理由がないんだだから仏教はそこは渇愛というんだよと A
とAとBが触れたら そこで感覚が生まれて
それから渇愛が生まれる
この順番なんですね で
必ず生まれる 渇愛の次に質問した方の顔を見ていないんですけど
よくウッパターナ 執着生まれたんですね
だからもう一度会いたい
永遠に末永く会いたいという気持ちがもう心の中で働いているんですね
それが執着のところですね
例えば執着が生まれなかったら
すぐ忘れちゃいます あのね
友達に あのね この間ね
すごい綺麗な可愛い女の子見たよとかね
これエロいピンさんでねとか言うだけで終わり
話はどこもどこも誰で知らない
そんなのはと ただなんかすごいインパクトということ
びっくりしまったよというだけで終わっちゃいます
だからそこはもう渇愛が生まれた
美しい女性を見て しかし
執着まではいかなかった
執着までいっちゃうと
もう一度ということになります
執着はいろいろ執着が生まれないわけじゃないんだけどね
年寄りの人が若い子を見たらね
それでも執着を生まれますけど
まあこの今の奥さんを捨ててこの人を失う
そこまではいかないんですね
これは無理やと また別な理性でわかりますね
だから理性が絡んできて
そこを邪魔してくれます
若者にはそこはないんですね
理性が絡んでこないんですね
一応そういう働きなんですね
だからどうするのかということは
私には聞かないでほしいんですけど
その方とね うまく一緒になれればね
自分が幸せだと思うでしょ
向こうは向こうは綺麗さっぱり断られたらね
結構落ち込んだりもするだろうと思いますね
だからそれを覚えておいてください
もし一緒になることができれば幸せになるかも
断られたら落ち込むかも
そのふうに置いちゃうと
自分の心が傷つかないで済みます
ですから 私から見れば
その女性を追っかけていって仲良くするのは構わないし
そのまま無視するのもどちらでも同じなんです
まあ執着はそれからあらゆる苦しみは運んではくれます
執着を運ぶのは幸せではないんです
幸せではないのであれば
ただの良い感覚は運んでくれますよ
今例に出した女性と一緒
一緒に慣れれば まあなんか肉体的な良い感覚を運んでくれる
その人と喋ると 心でいい気持ちという感覚を作ってくれる
それが幸せじゃないんです
ただ感覚ですね その代わりに悩みは運んでくれますね
心配 責任感 いろんなものは運んでくる
それからもう一つ大きな問題はね
自分がある日突然女性を見て一目惚れしてしまったでしょ
だからこれはリピートしないという保証がないでしょ
だって生きている上でね
いろんな人に会うでしょ
もっと自分の脳細胞がかっこいいとイメージ作る生命体にも会うんですよ
あれは脳のイメージのせいなんですよ
脳がある あの あるプログラムあってね
洗脳みたいなプログラムですけど
これなら綺麗 これなら綺麗じゃないとか基準作ってますよ
だからご自分の脳にできてあった基準にぴったしはめたんですね
自分の脳が持っていた美人の基準がありまして
これ基準に合っちゃったんです
合格なんですね だから脳が合格
この人は合格やと言っちゃったんです
それが一目惚れなんです
みんな人間の脳に美の基準があるんです
美の基準 醜いことの基準
気持ちいい基準 気持ち悪い基準
気分いろいろあるんです
基準に合っちゃうと もう脳は瞬時に判断するんです
決定と しかし 脳って機械だからね
あ この人に決定でしょ
それでまたあちこち行ったり
旅行したりすると 次に会った人は美女
美 美の基準は 80% 前の人は 65
どうします？これご自分に管理できないんです
脳がいきなり やっぱり 80%の方
そうなります だから気を付けるんですよ
女の人にね むちゃくちゃ怒られたっても
脳はそういうことなんです
それは女性も同じなんですよ
女性は男ほど不倫しないのは別な理由があるんです
脳は同じなんです 別に
この女性はこの人類にべったし束縛されてますからね
子供を産んで育てなくちゃあかんでしょ
この世を作らなくちゃあかんですね
だから男と遊ぶよりはもう大胆
大胆 大半の仕事は別なんです
脳の仕事は 遊ぶことはもうほんのわずかな部分なんです
大脳の大半は この世界を作って育てて維持管理することに生きてるんです
そこで女性がすごい喜びを感じるんです
朝から晩まで子供の面倒を見ることで
子供のために必死になることで
人に怒鳴りつけることで
何の躊躇もなく 場所も考えないで男に怒鳴るでしょ
だからそういう風にまあもう管理するんですね
そこで自分 女性がいわゆる女性の性別
性 メッテル生命は喜びを感じるんです
だから成功ってそんなに優先的じゃないんですね
それ優先的な方もいるんだけど
それは異常なんですね
だから男はちょっと違いますね
育てるという義務が入ってないんですね
だから男は子供育てるんじゃなくて
自分の結婚した相手を守っているんです
相手の希望なら何でも叶えてあげそうと思っているだけなんです
それで相手が子供の面倒見ろよと頼むんだからやってあげます
だからそういう単純生命体ですね
男性っていうのは だから単純
体も単純でしょ で そこで問題はこの美の基準ができてるでしょ
これ見た？あ これ 60%
今まで 60%の人を見たことない
合格を決めたと それでまた旅すると
やっぱり 80%のそこ行っちゃう
だから だから結婚しても
日本では4人に1人だそうですね 4
人に1人が 不倫をするというね
仏教はね よこしまな行為は一切やめなさいと言っているのは
こうやって脳と戦ってますよ
美人たちを目に触れても
結婚しているならば関係ないと執着捨てる
これで忙しいというふうに脳を戒めるんです
だから なんで好きになったかということの答えは
あれは脳が作った基準にあったんです
それだけです どうするのか
自分が世界で はい  ありがとうございました
上のほうの方 お手上げですか
真ん中女性の方から  今日はお話ありがとうございました
テレビとかで通り魔事件とかを見ていると
もし自分がその場にいた時にどうやって行動するかなって後で考えるんですけど
そう考えた時 自分はやっぱり自分が刺されたんじゃなければってなんか逃げ逃げてると思うんですけど
なんかそれっていうのはやっぱり性に対する執着なのかなって思って
なんかそういう場に遭遇した時に
自分はどういう風にすればいいんだろうということを解いていただきたいんですけど
お願いします 逃げてください
逃げられないんだったら
ものすごいデッカい声で泣き叫んでください
もう女性の声にはみんな怖がりますよ
知らない あの声に怖がらない人はいませんよ
動物でももう後ろを見ないで逃げますよ
それだけ別に まあ性に際の執着とかそんなこと言ってる場合じゃないでしょ
別に もしそこを通り魔事件で死ぬ運命だったら
これはもうどうしようもないんだけど
まあ命はなんとか守られる範囲で守る
守りますよ そんな難しいことじゃないんですね
しかし 人を疑うことだけはやめてください
ここ顔色悪くなるんです
体病気になるんですね
もしかすると怪しい人やとかね
ではなくて まあ人間さんみんな殺して生きてるんだというね
ニコニコと微笑み忘れないで生きてみてください
余計に信頼しない方もよろしい
だからといってね 人はまあ怪しい目では見ない
だからといって誰でも信頼する
それもやりません まあ誰にでも微笑みを見せると
ちょっとおかしいが 人が来たらもう徹底的に逃げると
逃げられない場合はもう攻撃
声の攻撃すれば OK です
ありがとうございました
すいません じゃあ続き
隣で手上げましたのでよろしくお願いします
今日のお話を聞いて 二三反省したり
教えていただくことがあります
一つは 自分が死ぬ時に
あの えっと 自分の母親が亡くなる時
臨終の時  10 日間一緒におれたことがとても自分の何か嬉しいというか
なんか充実した気分になれたんですけども
私が死ぬ時には まああの親しい人に手を手をずっと繋いでもらって
多分最後まで苦しんだと思いますので
手を握ってもらいたいなと思ったんですけども
これはやっぱり今日のお話を
いて 手を握ったりとか
体に触るとかいうことをせずに
一人で苦しみを耐え忍んで
まああの いくということの方がいいのかなと思いましたけども
いかがでしょうか  いや
結末ですかね 何か言ってるか分からない
今日の話を聞いて あ あの依存って言うんじゃないんですよ
そういう親しい人に手を
子供とか夫とか その辺りにずっと私が親にしたように
10日間くらいずっとそばにいてもらいたいなという希望があったんですけども
はい 今日の経典は聞いてないっていう話ですけどね
今日の経典ではいかなるものにも執着するなよって言ってるのに
そうです だからあの 他の人にも何か涙を
涙を流したりとか 人に触れてあーっていうような状況を作って
今まで自分が作ろうとしたものを
今日のお話を聞いて絶対してはいけないのだと私
今思ったんですけども
それでよろしいでしょうか
はいはい わかりました
はい わかりました ありがとうございました
執着捨てることが仏道であると
関わり持っちゃうと自分も苦しいし
相手にも苦しいんですね
だからご自分が執着があり方と思っていて
本当は苦しい世界を作ったんです
みんなに迷惑な世界 旦那にも迷惑
子供たちにも迷惑 自分にも迷惑
みんな精神的に壊れる世界を作っていたんですね
あれは執着がやったんですよ
で 犯人はご自分じゃなくて執着なんですね
だから執着を捨ててください
頑張って死んでいけばいい
うんうん まあ頑張るという言葉の意味はよくわかりませんけど
人に苦しみを耐え忍んでして亡くなるんです
とにかく執着という言葉を覚えて
無執着 無執着 無執着とかね
あるいは私の単語を使ってくれ
放っておく 放っておく
放っておく 気にしない
気にしない 気にしないとかね
関係ない 関係ないとかね
もう管理 管理の反 反外ですか
この言葉なんでえ 管轄外とかね
管理できないものは管轄外なんですね
自分が死んでる時は 死にかけてる時はね
旦那さんが来た方が 娘さん来た方がいいと思ったってもわからないですよ
そんなのは それで向こうはその気持ちがあったっても
来られることわからないでしょうね
それだったら母親が子供たちがそばにいてほしいと思っている
子供たちもやっぱりお母さんのそばにいてあげたいと思っている
しかし 何かがあって全く来られない
電車に乗って来ているんだけど
それより先に死んじゃったとかね
その間で母親が裏切れたとかね
これだけしか私は期待していないのに
ただそばにいてくださいと
今までここまでやっていて
恩返しとしてただそばにいてよと
それさえもやってくれなかったと思うことがどれほど苦しいんですかね
それで子供たちにしても
ああ お母さんのそばにいる気がくることできなかったと
一生苦しいもんですよ
だからこれ 執着ほどとんでもない鬼がいないんです
ありがとうございました
それではこれで終了したいと思います
最後に皆さんで回向の文を練習します
お返しをしてください
回向の文 仏法僧の三宝に礼拝致し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向をいたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が与えられますように
サッベーテワジャントーサッバローゴーナッサプーマテーバワトアントラヨーシケーディーバーイコバワバワトサッバマンガランラッカンサッバデーヴァタサッバムン
ダーヌバーヴェーナサッバダーマヌバーヴェーナサッバサンガーヌバーヴェーナサダースッティーバワントテーアビワタシーリーサーニッチャンワッダーポチャイノー
チャッターローダンマーヴァッダンテーアーユワノーシュカンバラン
はいはい はい 本当に長い時間よく頑張りましたね
どうもありがとうございます
ブッダンサラナンガチャー
に